This course will help you learn what you need
to implement graph algorithms and use them
to solve coding challenges. Alvin's dynamic
programming course is one of the most popular
courses on our channel. And now he's back
to teach you graph algorithms. Hey, programmers,
I'm Alvin from Structy. Welcome to our course
on graphs. And in particular, this is going
to be about graphs for your technical interviews.
Of course, graphs are a very common topic
when it comes to those technical interviews.
And in particular, what I want to emphasize
throughout this course, is the handful of
patterns that come up time and time again,
on those technical interviews. in just about
two and a half hours, I'm going to give you
all the tools you need to basically cover
I'd say about 80% of all graph problems. And
so what I have in store for this course, well,
I think the key to victory for your data structures
and algorithms, and especially your graphs
is to visualize things, right. So we're going
to do is trace through a lot of different
algorithms, and be sure to understand them
at a high level. And that means going through
different animations here, I think graphs
have a pretty bad rap for being a difficult
topic. Because to a beginner, you can have
very, very different narratives around a problem,
and not really understand. They're all really
based on a graph premise. So we're going to
realize that a bunch of different things can
be understood as graphs. So when it comes
to the prerequisites of this course, I'm going
to assume that you know nothing about graphs.
But you do know how to code, right, so I'm
going to have the expectation that you understand
some recursion. So as you work through the
course, and learn about different graph patterns,
we're going to use those patterns to solve
some very classic interview problems about
graphs, right. And I'm going to give you plenty
of opportunity to practice these patterns
in different problems that we will be ready
whenever you have them on a technical interview.
What I love about the topic of graphs is just
using a handful of different algorithms, you
can cover the majority of graph problems,
right. For every graph problem that we cover,
we're going to split it up into two sections,
section one is going to be about the approach
for the video. So we're going to go over the
strategy and overall theory, and be sure to
sketch out a nice meaningful picture. We're
also going to talk about the complexity of
the algorithm in the approach video. Following
every approach, we're also going to implement
the code of course, I'm going to be writing
all of my code in JavaScript, you'll be able
to follow along in any language that you like.
So that means occasionally I'll be switching
to my code editor where you of course can
follow along. We're also going to be sure
provide links in description as well as links
on screen. That way you can formerly you read
the prompts for every problem, as well as
look at the different test cases. Alright,
I think that's enough introduction. For now,
let's hop right into the course. Alright,
programmers. So let's jump right into the
course, I want to start by giving you some
background about your graphs, we're going
to go over the graph basics that you need
to start attacking problems in a technical
interview. So first off, what is a graph?
A graph is really just a collection of nodes
and edges. So with respect to nodes, you can
visualize them as typically just some circles
with some data inside of them. So I'll put
some letter values in my nodes over here.
And when we refer to edges, that would be
just any connections between nodes. So for
example, if there was a connection between
A and C, it would look something like this,
right? What I can formally say is there's
an edge between A and C, I can create many
edges between any nodes I want within this
graph. Another word you might hear out in
the wild when it comes to describing nodes,
as you might hear the word vertex being used,
right, they're really the same thing. In this
course, I'll stick to the word node. And an
edge is just a connection between a pair of
nodes. And that's really all a graph is at
a high level, where things get interesting
is how we can use this graph framework to
actually solve a problem, right. So if you
think of these nodes as just things and the
edges as relationships, a graph is grid describing
the relationship between things. For example,
we can say that the nodes here are cities
and edges would be roads connecting cities
are in a similar way, maybe our nodes here
are courses, and then the edges represent
prerequisites. And so in the future, we're
going to use graphs as a way to illustrate
and frame some narrative problem. Let's talk
about this graph. In particular, here, I really
have drawn a directed graph. And that's because
I have some arrowheads along the edges. That
would be a comparison to an undirected graph.
So here, I have really the same structure,
except I don't have any arrowheads on the
edges here. And that means that there is no
directionality to it right. If I look at the
directed graph, let's say I was at the node
A, well, then I can travel to B or C, let's
say I move to C. However, once I'm at C, I
cannot travel to a, I can only travel to E,
right? That's because I have to obey the direction
of the arrow heads here. By take a look at
my undirected graph, let's say I was currently
situated at the scene over here, that I do
have the option of traveling to either a or
E, right? So if I traveled to a, that's all
good, I can even travel back to C. So think
of as an undirected graph as a two way street.
For now we'll just continue on with our directed
version. Let me also introduce some useful
terminology we can use when talking about
the nodes in our graph. If I was currently
situated at this a node, I can refer to B
and C as neighbor nodes. Alright, so a neighbor
node is really any know that's accessible
through an edge, of course, obeying the direction
of the edge. In other words, if I was currently
situated at the sea node, that I only have
one neighbor of E, right, if I'm at the sea,
you know, then I won't consider a neighbor.
Awesome. When you visualize graph algorithms,
you should really sketch a picture that looks
just like this, right literally drop nodes
as circles and arrows as your edges here.
However, when it comes to how we implement
this algorithm in some code, we're gonna have
to represent it in a more programmatic way.
Right? So in my brain, I think of this image
of like nodes and arrows between them. However,
in my program, I'm going to use typically
an adjacency list, it's probably our preferred
way to represent and graph information, right.
So depending on the programming language of
choice we're going to use typically, we would
use some hash map data structure to represent
an adjacency list. Really, we're looking forward
to using some constant time, I'll look up
data structure that has a key value pair mapping,
right. So if you're in JavaScript, they'll
be an object, if you're in Python, they'll
be a dictionary. If you're in a language like
Java, or C, you'll be using an unordered map.
Looking at this hash map, I have drawn or
this adjacency list, the keys of this adjacency
list are going to be every node in my graph,
right, so I just have all of the node values
A through F laid out as the keys. However,
if you look at the corresponding values, the
values are actually going to be an array,
right? So if I look at this very first entry,
it says that I have a node of a and then in
the array of populated all of the neighbors
have a that is a has two neighbors have BNC.
That's why I have this correspondence within
my adjacency list. That holds true for every
entry within my adjacency lists. So for example,
let's say look at the entry for e. So I go
to the spot and make j c list where the key
is E, it only has a one outgoing edge to be.
That's why the array for he only has be inside
of it. One thing to also note is even if a
node has no neighbors, it should still appear
as a key within my adjacency list. For example,
if you look at the D, node D has no outgoing
edges. That's why its neighbor array is empty.
However, it should still at least appear as
a key within my adjacency lists, right, that
way, you can still know that the D node exists.
So at the start of the course, will usually
be taking in adjacency list as the information
to represent a graph, right. But as we sketch
through things on the whiteboard, we should
be visualizing them using a nice picture like
this. Awesome. So let's actually jump into
our first pair of algorithms. To me, the must
know algorithm for a graph is really going
to be to do some sort of traversal on it.
Why don't we start by talking about a depth
first traversal, something you may have heard
of before, right, now we're going to talk
about the depth first traversal algorithm
that operates on a graph. So let's start by
understanding at a high level what order a
depth first traversal would give you. So let's
say I had some starting node, and I'm gonna
choose a as my starting node, right, so I'm
gonna color it here in yellow. If I was following
a depth first traversal. Now that I've, you
know, chosen as my starting point, I can either
hit B or C. Next, I'm just gonna commit to
using B. So let's say I had the sequence so
far have a comma b. And at this point, if
I was truly following a depth first traversal,
I must go deeper to the D node. In other words,
I don't go to the C node yet. Cool, that would
be a true depth first traversal, right. At
this point, now that I've bottomed out at
D, D is a dead end, right? I can't travel
to F from D, because that would be disobeying
the arrowhead. And so now I can move to that
other neighbor of C. And from here, the algorithm
would continue, right, I go from C to E, and
then e to B. And technically, I would have
to double traverse some nodes like B and D
over here. So overall, in this yellow coloring,
I have colored the full region that a depth
first traversal would explore starting at
a notice that if you started at a it would
be impossible to reach F. And that's kind
of normal, right? That's kind of why we use
these traversal algorithms that can tell you
whether or not you can travel between some
nodes. And we'll see that literal problem
later on. Right? So you're probably wondering,
you know, exactly how do we implement this,
but for now, I just want to stay focused on
the order that we got, right. So just regarding
our depth first traversal, we remember the
first three iterations of the algorithm, we
hit the sequence of a B, D, right, that's
indicative of a depth first traversal. Now
let's compare that to the breadth first Marion.
So I'm going to lay down the same exact graph,
we're also going to start a traversal at the
a node, but this time follow a breadth first
order. So I have a first and let's say, you
know, I chose B as my next node when it comes
to breadth first traversal. It doesn't matter
like which, you know, initial neighbor you
choose, so I'm just gonna choose B. But now
that I've chosen B, if I was following a true
breadth first traversal, I must hit c next,
right. And that's the main difference between
our depth first and breadth first reversals
for the same graph, my depth first would start
a B, D, whereas my breadth first would start
a, b, c. And so you're probably wondering,
is there any importance between this nuance
right? When would I prefer depth first over
breadth first, or vice versa? Either a depth
first or breadth first traversal would explore
the same exact nodes within a graph. However,
it would explore them in a different order,
right? And this is more obvious to see when
we have a larger graph with way more edges.
And so let's look at how he depth first traversal
explores again, but this time on a much larger
graph, let's take a look at this one. So I'm
going to choose some random node as a starting
point, let's say I chose this node in yellow,
that was doing a depth first traversal, what
I'm going to do is, you know, pick a direction
and travel in that same direction as far as
possible before switching directions. So let's
say I move to the right, at this point, I
would have to continue moving toward the right,
until I can't move to the right any longer,
at which point, I have to choose some new
directions, let's say it was downward. I'll
keep doing that until I can't move downward
anymore. And so I'd have to move to the left
now, now I'd keep chasing this single path
in a very deep direction. So that's behavior
indicative of a depth first traversal, right,
you're exploring one direction as far as possible
before switching directions. Let's compare
that to a breadth first traversal. So let's
say start at the same node in pink, if I was
following a breadth first traversal, it would
look something like this. From the starting
point, I would explore all of the immediate
neighbors of this node, kind of in a circle
like this. Now I just keep applying that behavior.
So as you notice about the breadth first traversal,
is it'll tend to explore you know, all directions
evenly, right, instead of just favoring One
Direction all the way through. That's really
the only difference between a depth first
and breadth first traversal. Later on the
course, I'll bring up explicit problems where
you might prefer one over the other. All right,
but for now, what I want to do is give you
all the background you need. So you can actually
build this algorithm will kind of talk about
things at a high level, consider this the
pseudocode, then, of course, we'll express
it in some JavaScript code later on. So when
it comes to actually implementing in code,
these two algorithms, the key is to understand
that a depth first traversal uses a stack,
and a breadth first traversal uses a queue,
recall that a stack is something where you
add to the top and remove from the top as
well, or is it Q is something where you add
to the back and remove from the front, and
it gives you two very different orderings.
That's really the only difference between
these two algorithms. So let's start by tracing
through our depth first traversal, of course,
using a stack, so I'm going to use a slightly
different graph. And to visualize my stack,
I'm going to use this bar to represent the
bottom of my stack, obviously, for me, at
least I think of a stack as some vertical
data structure. Cool. So let's say I just
arbitrarily chose a as my starting node to
perform my depth first traversal, right, in
the long run, just want to print out all different
node values within this graph. So what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take my starting node
of a, and I'm just gonna immediately initialize
it onto my stack. So right now as the only
thing on my stack, it's also at the top of
my stack. And now I can enter the flow of
the main algorithm here, because I have a
stack, what I can only do is remove the top
of my stack. So that means I pop off a from
the stack, and consider the a node, my current
node being looked at, right? At this point,
let's say I print out a to my console. And
from here, what I want to do is consider A's
neighbors, right. So if I look at the C node,
what I should do is just push c to the stack,
then also push B to the stack, right. And
it doesn't matter like in which order you
push these neighbors. If I want it to hit
B first, then I'm going to push them second,
right? Awesome. That would end like my first
iteration of this depth first traversal. Cool.
So at this point, I can look at my stack,
and my stack still has some data on it. So
I should do is again, pop the top of my stack.
So I'm going to pop and be off my stack. And
that becomes my current, I'm also going to
print it out. At this point, I look at B's
neighbors, B has one neighbor of D and so
I push d to the top of the stack. Notice that
because I have a stack D ends up on top of
the C, right. And so now when I get to another
iteration, when I pop the top of my stack,
I look at the D node as my current, right,
and I can print out D. And this feels good
because so far, my print order would be a
BD, notice that I kind of pursued that single
path deeply following a BD. But I have to
look at DS neighbors, I can take f and just
push f to the top of my stack. next iteration,
my stack is still on empty. So I should do
is pop the top F is now my current, I can
print out F, but f has no neighbors. So F
isn't going to push anything else to the top
of the stack. Right? At this point, I get
to this next pass, and I pop the top of my
stack. And that means C is now my current,
I can print out CS value. And then I can look
at Sue's neighbors. And I just push e to the
top of my stack. On this last iteration, I
popped up on my stack, he is now my current
I print out he since he has no neighbors,
I don't push anything else to the top of my
stack. And at this point, I've reached the
state where my stack is empty. And that means
my algorithm is done right that means you
explored as far as possible within your graph.
Notice that it might not necessarily be the
case that you're able to hit every node of
the graph. And this particular example it
was possible though, awesome. So let's redo
that trace using Our breadth first algorithm,
which means we just adjust things slightly.
And we use a queue order. Remember that a
queue is a first in first out data structure,
meaning things enter to the back, and then
they leave from the front. And so let's say
I use this arrow to represent the directionality
of my queue, right. And I start the algorithm
in the same way for my breadth first traversal.
Let's say I want it to begin at node A. So
I just initialize my queue with a cool, so
I start by removing the front of my queue.
So a becomes my current node, I can print
out a as well. And now I consider A's neighbors,
right. So I consider B and C. If I wanted
to travel to B before C, then I should push
B to my queue first, right, so I add B to
the back of my queue, right. And I should
also add c to the back of my queue, right.
And that would actually end my first iteration.
So now I look at my queue still has some stuff
on it. So I removed the front of my queue,
that means B becomes my current. Of course,
I print out B. Now I consider B's neighbors.
So I just look at the D node, and I push d
to the back of the queue, since D enters through
the back and ends up behind the C, and that's
really important behavior. next iteration,
I removed the front of my queue. So my current
is now see, right, I can print out see, and
then look at sees neighbors of just E and
I add e to the back of the queue, which means
that in the order of my queue, he ends up
behind the my next iteration, I removed D
from the queue, and I print out the edits
neighbor of F to the back of my queue. next
iteration, I removed e from the front of my
queue, print it out. Since he has no neighbors,
he is not going to add anything else to the
back of the queue. And of course, finally,
f leaves the front of my queue, I print out
F, F has no neighbors, at which point now
my queue is totally empty. And since our queue
is empty, that would be the end of our algorithm.
Alright, and that's all there is to our depth
first and breadth first algorithms, they're
going to be the nice baseline code that we
use to solve many different graph problems.
I think that's enough theory. For now, what
I want to do is now switch to my code editor,
where you can actually implement these in
JavaScript, hey, programmers, here I am in
my editor, what I want to do is now show you
how to implement those depth first and breadth
first algorithms. So we'll start with the
depth first. And my goal is really just to
build a function that will print out all of
my values in the graph, according to a depth
first traversal, right, we're going to define
this function depth first print, making an
arrow function in JavaScript, it's going to
take in the graph, which is going to be given
as a nice adjacency list. And this is actually
the same graph. Now last example we traced
out, I'm also going to need to specify some
starting node here, I'll call it a source
node, we're going to begin the traversal.
Starting at that node. Cool. And so we know
inherent to a depth first traversal is going
to be a stack. So I'll show you how to implement
this iteratively, which means you need an
explicit stack. For me in JavaScript, that's
as simple as just using a JavaScript array,
right? I'll make it empty at the start. And
I can use this array as a stack, if I just
commit to using operations that manipulate
the same end of the array. In other words,
if I just use push and pop, that will always
manipulate the end of the array, right? removing
and adding to the end of that array. What
I want to actually be sure to do is I want
to initialize the stack with my starting node,
that is with my source node. Remember that
like a node here is really just designated
by some character. Cool. And when it comes
to designing like the main loop for the algorithm
here, do you want to keep running the algorithm
while the stack is not empty? In other words,
wall stack dot length is bigger than zero,
that I have to keep running. That's very reminiscent
to what we expressed on the whiteboard. So
when it comes to performing like a single
iteration of this depth first, what I want
to do is remove the top of my stack. So if
I do stack dot pop, that will remove the last
item of an array, in this case like the top
of my stack, and also return it to me. So
I'm going to save that to a variable, I'll
call it my current. And so this point would
actually be a great opportunity to just print
out that current. So I'll console dot log
current, right? So looking at, you know, this
example over here, since I initialize a stack
to contain just the source note of a, on the
very first iteration, this while loop, I would
of course, pop out a, then I would print it
out, right. And from that point, what I want
to do is consider A's neighbors of B and C.
So if I want to look at like the array associated
with a, I can just key into my graph, right,
cuz my graph is an object right now. So if
I say graph, square bracket, current, right,
if current is a, that means graph, square
bracket current would give me back this array.
I want to iterate through every node or every
neighbor in that array. So I'm going to nest
a loop here. And I say for let neighbor of
that array. So if you're familiar in JavaScript,
if you just use a for of loop, they'll iterate
an order through an array. So now I'm hitting
a neighbor as B and neighbors see. What I
want to do with those neighbors is simply
Push them to the top of my stack. So that
will just be stacked up, push and push this
neighbor. Awesome, I'm going to be sure to
push every single neighbor that has. So sometimes
I'll have two neighbors. Other times I'll
have one neighbor, or even no neighbors. That's
really all there is to implementing a nice
baseline depth first print. Something that
I do want to point out, my favorite way to
implement this algorithm is to consider like
processing your node, when it leaves the stack,
not when it enters the stack. In other words,
I usually write like my print statement, right
after something is popped. And the thing that
I pop is exactly what I print. Right. So let's
go ahead and give this a run, see what we
get. It looks like in my terminal, I got the
order of AC e b df, which you'll notice is
slightly different from what I expected from
over here. However, this would be also a valid
depth first traversal, we have to bear in
mind is you know, depending on like the arbitrary
order of values within the same neighbor's
array, you could tend a different direction
at first, right? Most important thing I look
for when it comes to verifying a depth first
is to make sure that I you know, chase the
same direction before switching directions,
right. So since I started out with a C, so
I go a and then to a C over here, the next
move would be going to E and that's exactly
what happened in my code, right. And then
once I hit E is actually a dead end. So then
I can go on to my other lateral neighbor like
B, right. And so I can contrive the same order
expected here, if I just flipped this right.
And so I put c followed by B. I'll give that
around. They're both valid. depth first traversals.
See what we got now. Cool, now I get the exact
order of A, B, D, F, C. And really think about
why that is, right. So let's say that I just
popped out a from my stack. So I printed out
a that's nothing fancy, right. And then from
there, I start iterating through the array
that's associated with a right, so on the
first iteration, I iterate through C, right?
If I push C on the stack, let's say this is
the bottom my stack, by pushing on the stack,
it's right here. Then followed by that I pushed
B on the stack. Now B is on top. Since B is
on top, I know like the next top level iteration,
this while loop, I would remove B and that's
going to be the next note I visit. And so
they're really both depth for sure Russell's.
Nice. So two things to note, you're definitely
going to use a stack to implement depth reversal.
And you can use the stack in a few different
ways. Right? So here I'm using like an explicit
like array as a stack. And I'm implementing
this using some iterative code, right. So
using a few loops, right, what you can also
do is implement depth first recursively, because
I know any recursion uses the underlying call
stack. So let me show you how to implement
that as well. And when it comes to, you know,
having all these different tools in your arsenal,
I would definitely practice both the iterative
and recursive flavors. We'll see that later
on in this course. So let's say I wanted to
solve the same problem. But now recursively,
it's actually going to be less code. So I'm
going to have the same sort of arguments,
I'm going to have the graph which is the adjacency
list as well as a source node, consider like
the source node as like your current location.
So if I'm at some node, maybe the first thing
I should do is just print out myself, right,
print out this node, so I'll do is console
dot log, this source node. And that feels
good just from the get because when we actually
do a top level call to this recursive function,
they're passing in a as the source node. So
I do want to begin a as a first note in my
print, and then from there, I need to look
at AES neighbors. Well, if you want to look
at as neighbors like before, just key into
the graph, adjacency list using that node,
right, and this would give me an array of
CNB. Now I just iterate through that array.
So I'll say for let neighbor of that array.
And at this point, what I want to do is now
do the recursion, right, so I make a recursive
call on each of these neighbors. So for me,
that means just called depth first print,
you give the same graph, right, the graph
object doesn't change, but you should change
like the source node. Now you want to pass
in that neighbor as the source node. And you're
going to make a recursive call for every neighbor
in that array. And this would actually be
all we need. Let's go ahead and just run this
version. divider run over here. Looks like
now we get the order AC E, B, D, F. And that's
really again, another type of depth first
print, right, not exactly this order, because
this time we chased c first, right, we went
a C, I want to get exactly this ordering and
my recursion, then I would have to put in
B first, really same sort of pattern. Now
let's get that into the run. Good AB de FC.
One thing I want to bring up about this recursive
first is it has no explicit base case, meaning
there's no obvious like, if statement that
just like returns like you'd typically see
in most recursion. That's because in this
problem I have an implicit base case when
a node like he is a dead end. All right, let's
say my current source coming in is he, well,
then when I iterate in this for loop, I'm
iterating through this empty array, I mean
to have zero iterations. If you have zero
iterations, then you never make a recursive
call. Right? That's the same thing as having
a base case, right? A base case is really
just a scenario where we don't have a recursive
call. So that's how this code still works.
Alright, so now you know how to implement
depth first in two ways, right, iterated and
recursively. And they both use definitely
a stack. Let me now show you how to implement
your breadth first, right as well comment
out some of this code. Now we'll do a nice
breath first, give myself some room over here.
So for a breadth first, we want to solve the
swan iteratively. And it's really only possible
iteratively, right. So I know a breadth first
traversal demands a queue, if you try to like
implement a breadth first traversal using
some recursion, and under the hood, there's
some stack data structure, that's going to
fight against the queue order that you want,
right? So for breadth first traversal, you're
always typically going to be writing some
iterative code. So some loops, right? Let
me define this, I'll say breadth first print,
take in the full graph, adjacency list, as
well as the source node, I want to initialize
my queue. With that source note, again, the
queue here is just going to be an array in
JavaScript. So I'll say const q equals an
array that begins with just the source node.
Awesome. And I'm going to use this queue by
just committing to two specific methods on
my arrays in JavaScript. So if I use array
dot shift that removes the first element of
an array. If I do array dot push that adds
to the last position of an Array. And using
those two methods in combination would give
me a nice cue, right, add to one end and remove
from the other end. So like before, we're
gonna have a while loop, we're gonna iterate
while our queue is not empty. And so while
queue dot length is bigger than zero, nice.
And same thing as our iterative, you know,
at first, you want to start by just removing
the front of your queue. So I'll say q dot
shift, that will remove the first element
as well as return it to me. So I can save
in a variable, I like to call it current,
just like the whiteboard, right? And from
there, maybe I'll print it out. So console
dot log, this current node. And from here,
just consider your neighbors, right. So if
I key into my graph, using this current node,
that gives me an array of its neighbors, I
want to loop through each of those neighbors.
So I can say four will say let neighbor of
that array. And for that neighbor, I want
to add them to the back of my queue. So for
me, that would mean simply q dot push, I'm
going to go ahead and push that neighbor.
Awesome. So I remove from the front, and I
add to the back. So that looks pretty good.
Let's go ahead and give it a run. And actually,
before I do that, I'm going to change the
order of this, put the CNB. Again, doesn't
really matter the relative order for neighbors,
I just want this exact output, and we'll talk
about why that is right. Give that a run.
So I get ACB EDF just like I expected ACB
EDF, right. So let's say you're on the first
iteration of this breadth first print, I know
that I would have just removed a because I
initialized a on the queue, right? So my current
is a and I print out a and then from there,
I start iterating through this array, right.
So on the first iteration, I have C, that
means I put c into my queue, right? And then
afterwards, I put B, if you put C and then
B, that means C is at the front of the queue,
which is why on the second iteration, I have
C first, right? So that's how you can manipulate
potentially the lateral order of a breadth
first print. Awesome. That's all there is
to this traversal algorithm, what I really
want emphasizes, especially if you look at
the apples to apples iterative code, you compare
depth first or breadth first, it's almost
identical code. You're really just changing
how you access items in your array, right?
You either pop or push or you shift and push
harder than that the whole like structure
of this code is identical, right? All right.
So that's our introduction on depth first
and breadth first for our graphs. In the next
section, we're going to start to solve a problem,
right, which will be really fun. I'm just
utilizing this code as our baseline tool.
And then that section also promised that start
doing the analysis for bego of these algorithms.
So let's jump back to that whiteboard. Hey,
programmers, welcome back, right, and let's
go over the approach for this has path problem.
So in this problem, we're gonna take in an
adjacency list representing a graph for this
problem, and really all graph problems, you
definitely want to visualize this one with
a picture. And so what we'll do is we'll interpret
each key of this adjacency list as representing
a distinct node. And if I look at any particular
list, I can see that this f node should point
to G and I. And they do tell us in this problem
that I have a directed graph. So I'm going
to draw arrowheads on these edges here. So
F points to G, as well as f points tie. And
I'll create similar edges based on the information
in the given graph. So we end up with an image
like this, until they tell us that this is
a directed graph that explains the arrowheads,
but they also tell us that this graph is a
cyclic. So if you're unfamiliar, a cyclic
just means No cycles, that kind of begs the
question, what is a cycle in a graph. So a
cycle would be a some path through nodes,
where I can end up where I want started. In
other words, if I started at the a node over
here that I can go to B, then from there,
I can go to C, then back to a, and so on and
so forth. So if I did a traversal, on the
Sigma graph, I would get an infinite loop.
And what they're saying is, our graph input
is guaranteed to be directed. So it has arrowheads,
but also a cyclic, so we don't have to consider
any infinite cycles here. That being said,
In this problem, we also want to take in not
only the graph information, but also a source
and destination node, we want to do is return
true or false indicating whether or not we
can travel from the source node to the destination
node. In other words, is there a path that
exists between those two nodes? For this problem,
you can use either a depth first or breadth
first search to actually solve the problem
here, I'll trace through in this approach
video, just the depth first search. But in
the walkthrough, I'll be sure to code it up
both ways. So let's say started at my source
node, I know that if I was doing a depth first
traversal, I can either choose the IRG, let's
say happen to choose to G next. Now I have
no choice, right? If I'm doing truly a depth
first, I should go deeper to the H. So then
I hit this H. And as I traverse through these
different nodes, I need to ask myself if my
current node is equal to my destination. So
far, that hasn't been true. At this point,
I bottomed out with my h node, I can't travel
any deeper. So now I can move laterally to
a node like I, at this point from I can either
move to a K or a G, let's say by luck, I just
happen to go to the G, this would actually
bring me down a path I've explored previously,
which we can optimize later on, but wouldn't
be too much of a big deal. Eventually, if
I continued this depth first search through
the graph, I would end up at a node that matches
my destination, at which point I can return
true signifying that there must be some path
from F to k, just doing a depth first search.
And as we do this depth first search, it's
really important that you obey the directions
of your arrows. So I should never try to travel
upstream. So that was a scenario where we
were able to find a path from source of destination.
That's why we return true. Let's reset and
say that now, I should return false. Alright,
so let's say my source was J. So I start at
J. And I'm trying to get to my destination
of F. If I start a depth first traversal,
here, sorry, my j node traveled to the AI
node. At this point, I can hit either the
G, okay, let's say I happen to hit the k,
this point of bottom now. So now I can move
to the G. And then from there to the H. And
at this point, there's actually nowhere else
I can go, right. So if I finish my traversal
through the graph, using either a depth first
or breadth first and I never hit my destination,
then I can just return false, right? It must
be the case that there is no such path from
my source to my destination. When it comes
to implementing the depth first and breadth
first reversals on this graph, it's going
to be exactly what we're used to, you can
either use a stack and solve it recursively.
Or you can do it iteratively. And use a queue
in which case you'd be doing the breadth first
traversal. We talked about the complexity
of this, let's say that n is the number of
nodes of our graph, a common thing that you
can also do with these graph problems is define
e as the number of edges here and edges refers
to a connection between two nodes, basically
just the arrows. So if we use these two terms
of number nodes and number edges, we would
have a time complexity of our V o of the number
of edges as because we would have to travel
through every single edge of our graph. Here,
the space complexity would be based on the
number of nodes, right? If I solved it, recursively,
or even iteratively, with some sort of a depth
first stack, then the worst case, I would
have to have every single node on the stack,
right? Likewise, if I saw the eternity with
a breadth first I would have every single
node on the queue. So that's just one way
we can define the terms for analyzing the
time and space of this graph. Typically, for
graph problems, another acceptable way to
analyze the time and space of your algorithm
is to just use a single variable and just
define n as the number of nodes. That's because
if you say n is the number of nodes, then
we can also say that n squared would be the
number of edges, or that big O. It's about
the worst case. So let's imagine the worst
case graph. Let's say I just had these nodes
of ABC. Well, if I wanted to create as many
edges as possible, how would I just create
a single edge? Well, an edge is just a connection
between two nodes. So you could just really
draw an edge for every pair of nodes in your
graph, something like this. And that's why
we can say that n squared is the number of
edges of any particular graph. And so if you
just wanted to use n to define the complexity
here, then you could say that your time is
going to be O of n squared, and your space
complexity would still be O of n. Do know
that these are both two valid ways for defining
the complexity for a very typical graph problems.
That being said, I think this is pretty straightforward.
Let's hop into the walkthrough video while
we're actually implement both a depth first
and breadth first solution for these. I'll
see you there. Hey, programmers, Alvin here,
right now. Let's go over Ah, JavaScript solution
for this has path problem. And so we'll jump
right in, we're gonna start by solving this
one using a depth first traversal, which I
know requires some underlying stack data structure,
I'll just implement that using recursion.
So I can leverage the call stack to get my
ordering. And so I'm gonna solve this recursively,
I'm gonna consider my source argument as like
my current position during the traversal.
And so I can have a base case in check. All
right, if my source is equal to my destination,
that I must have found the thing I'm looking
for. So just return true. This base case signifies
that I found my destination. So there must
exist a path. And so I return true, always
paying attention to the type that they want
us to return for this function. Let's say
it's not true, well, they need to keep looking.
So what I should do is consider my current
node, which is source, consider its neighbors.
If I key into my adjacency list, I know that
this is going to be an object. So I key into
it using my source, that would give me an
array of all of its neighbors. So for example,
let's say it was staring at this one, if my
current source was F, and I say graph square
bracket, F, I would get back an array of gi.
So now I want to look through the neighbors,
right? So I can see over here is turned us
into a loop and say for that neighbor of those
neighbors, I want to traverse to them, which
means I call recursively. Right call has path,
keep your graph the same, but update your
current position. Now I'm going to be situated
at the neighbor. And the destination stays
the same, right, always have the same goal
to get to solving this one recursively. So
think about what type of this is going to
return, I know it's going to give back Boolean,
right, it's going to tell me whether or not
there is some path between my neighbor and
the destination, right. So if there's some
connecting point, or some connecting path
between my neighbor and the destination, then
I know that there must be some path from my
source to the destination, because your source
is definitely next to your neighbor, right.
So there would be a path between all of us.
And so what I'll do is, check if this recursive
call returns true, I'll make it explicit here,
maybe it's clear. And so if there is some
path through my neighbor to the destination,
then I can return true, just pass that true
upward. Because once I find a path, you can
just exit out and return that shoe all the
way back to the top level of color. But let's
say that this call returned false, that means
that there is no path through my neighbor
to the destination. But it couldn't be the
case that some other neighbor is actually
going to work out. And so what I don't want
to do is just say like else return false,
you should be able to immediately catch that
code like this as suspect because there's
no point of having a for loop then right?
If in either case, you're always going to
return, then you're never going to have a
second iteration of this for loop, right?
So if I don't find a path through my neighbor,
so if this call returns false, then that's
okay. Just continue on to the next iteration,
and search through your other neighbor. that
begs the question, Where should we return
false, needs to be after the for loop? So
only after I searched through all of my neighbors,
and I never find a winning path? Should I
return false, and that'd be our nice depth
first traversal. Let's give that a test run.
Awesome. There we have it. One thing to bear
in mind here, we are leveraging the assumptions
in the problem, right, they tell us straight
up that the graph is going to be given is
a sick like, so there are no cycles. So that's
why in our code, we didn't really worry about
getting trapped in an infinite loop. In our
upcoming problems, we'll have harder grass
to actually deal with that sick case. But
for now, this is a good baseline solution.
While we're here, let's also do a reference
solution, which you know, by now should be
iterated, right, there's no way to do like
a breadth first recursively. And so I need
to create my own queue. So I can create a
queue, kind of in a pinch, I always just use
an array in JavaScript, I'm gonna initialize
that queue with my source on it. So I'm gonna
refer to like source and destination, they're
really nodes. But in the context of like our
problem, they're really just given us strings,
but they represent nodes, right? So think
about the information they represent. I'm
going to iterate while my queue is not empty.
So while q dot length is bigger than zero,
should be familiar code, very similar to our
tree algorithms. And I start a single iteration
of reference by removing the front of my queue.
So I can say q dot shift some of the front,
I can call that my current node that I'm traversing
through. And now that something has left the
queue, typically here is where I check, I
can check. All right, if a thing I just visited,
if that is my destination, then I can just
return true, right, I found the thing I'm
looking for. So there must be a path that
connects my original source and my destination.
Nice. But let's say this was not true. Well,
then I need to consider its neighbors. So
like before, look at the neighbors just key
into your graph using the source like it's
a graph, square bracket source. That gives
me an array of all of the neighbors, all the
neighbor nodes. That's what I want to do here
is iterate through every neighbor Over there.
And then I can just add them into my queue.
So q dot push that single neighbor, and do
be sure to implement your true breadth first.
So you need to make things leave from one
end of your queue, and you add to the other
end. So this codes looking good. So you should
realize how similar This is to our old like
binary tree breadth first, except now we have
to account for the fact that we could have
like a dynamic amount of neighbors here, not
just dot left and dot, right. So I'm just
iterating through all those neighbors adding
them, I need to wait to return false. And
you guessed it, the move is after you finish
this entire while loop, if your cube becomes
empty, then you must have explored as far
as you could. And if you never return true,
and now you can return false, because it must
be the case that there is no path between
the original source and your target. So let's
give this a test run will have a very similar
time and space complexity. But this would
be the code for all of my iterative fans.
So here I'm getting a little error. Let's
see what we did wrong here. So it looks like
I timed out here. Let's see bug this one together,
I had to guess that means I did something
wrong getting trapped in an infinite loop.
This condition looks okay, right q dot length
greater than zero. And so here it is, must
be the case that I'm not correctly iterating
through the neighbors here, I just wrote source.
Instead, I need to say current, because now
I'm doing this iteratively, right. So whatever
node has just left my queue, I consider that
nodes neighbors and add them to be visited
next through my queue. So let's give that
a test run. honest mistake there. Cool. And
there's our breadth first solution for this
has path problem. So what I want you to do
is practice both the depth first and the breadth
first, like you expect, we're going to do
a lot of graph problems coming up. And depending
on you know what the problem is asking sometimes
will prefer one type of algorithm over the
other. So it's really important that you practice
both of these algorithms. Now, all the problems
are relatively easy. So practice this, give
it a shot on your own. And I'll catch you
in the next problem. See you there. Hey, programmers,
Alvin here, right. Now let's go over the approach
for this undirected path problem. So we'll
jump right in. In this problem, we're going
to be given an edge list for a undirected
graph. So if I are familiar with the terminology
here, really what we're saying is every pair
and this edge list represents a connection
between two nodes. For example, if I look
at the first edge, and the list, I see i comma
j, that means that there's a edge or connection
between i and j. And since this is an undirected
graph, not only can I directly travel from
i to j, but I can of course, move from j to
i. So it really represents a connection in
both directions. And so as we start to attack,
this problem we'll want to do is actually
convert this edulis into a more favorable
format, like an adjacency list. That's because
typically, when we perform our traversal algorithms,
they work best on an adjacency list form.
So let's start by doing that conversion here.
And I'll actually be pretty easy to code up.
So I want to basically generate a graph where
I have nodes as keys, I want them to point
to a an array of their neighbors. For example,
if I wanted to convert the first edge into
an adjacency list form, what I can do is create
keys for i and j. Now that I is a neighbor
of J, and also j is a neighbor of I, so I'm
going to populate those neighbors respectively.
Now just follow this process for another edge.
So if I look at the edge, k comma i, I need
to create a new key for K. And I'm going to
populate that with I and then for the existing
key of I, I just add k into that collection.
So do bear in mind, the most important thing
about this conversion is because we know that
the graph is going to be undirected, whenever
you put a connection within your graph, make
sure that you have the inverse connection.
So if I have an edge from k to AI, they also
need to have information for it. Okay. And
this process would just continue for the entire
list of edges. And by the end of this conversion,
we'll end up with an adjacency list just like
this. And now we're ready to perform our main
algorithm. When we go through the code walkthrough
for this, I'll show you in depth how you can
actually create this adjacency list. And so
when we want to actually come up with a traversal
algorithm to solve a graph problem, it really
helps if you actually visualize the shape
of your graph. So actually want to visualize
this in terms of nodes and edges. That means
a bunch of circles and lines between them.
If you drew out a nice picture for this graph
information, you would end up with a diagram
like so. And so we'll go through the rest
of this approach video just referencing this
diagram. Something important I want to bring
up at this point is for this graph, a very
common case we'll have to handle is what if
your graph has a cycle. And that's especially
true for your undirected graphs. And so just
for the purposes of this approach video, I'm
going to add an additional edge just so we
can talk about an explicit cycle. So I'm going
to add one new edge from k to J. Cool. The
reason is now there's a nice big cycle of
length three highlighting in red right now.
And this cycle is important to watch out for
because if we don't do any special handling
Then we may get trapped in an infinite traversal.
So imagine I started at this keynote, and
next I moved to J, then I would move to i,
and then back to k, and then back to J, and
then I, and so on. So now it gives me a cycle,
we'll have to guard against that. And so I
can have a cycle of three nodes here, right,
and you can really have a cycle of basically
almost any size, as long as it's more than
one. So for example, if I took a look down
here, notice that my graph actually contains
technically like two separate islands, but
we would consider them as just one giant graph,
right? So I've got the small island of O and
N, they actually form a trivial cycle, right?
If I started traversal, at o. From there,
I can move to n. And because I know that the
edge between o and n is bi directional writes
an undirected graph, that means I can travel
back to O, and then back to n. And this would
give me cyclic behavior. So have to watch
out for all types of cycles in this problem.
So in the context of this problem, not only
are we given a graph, we're also going to
take in a two nodes. So let's step through
an example where I want to return true or
false, is there a path between I and L. So
I'm going to mark those in my graph Israel.
So I'm going to start at the notify. And to
solve this one, you can use any type of traversal.
So either depth first or breadth first, I'll
step through explicitly the depth first traversal.
Right. Now, in order to avoid any infinite
traversals, I want to mark my nodes as visited
as I travel through them. So not only do I
situate myself at this source note of I, but
I'm gonna mark it as visited. And you can
implement this like marking a visited pattern.
And a few different ways. When we code this
up later on, we're probably going to use a
set to represent what we have visited. But
for now, I'll just check them off in my diagram.
And so in my diagram, if you see a checkmark
next to a node, that means that I already
have visited it. So since I'm at this node
of I want to move to its neighbors, so I'm
gonna move to the neighbor of J. And I'll
also be sure to check it off as visited. At
this point, I can move to one of Jays neighbors,
let's say I move to k. And I'm also going
to mark it as visited. Now then Matt K, I
can move to a few different neighbors, I could
either move to I LRM. Let's say by chance
I chose I, I once I get to this, I know, I'm
immediately going to be able to see that,
oh, I visited this node previously. So what
I should do is not travel through it again.
Instead, I should go back to the K, right,
because this eye node is already visited.
And that's where I actually avoid the infinite
loop. So instead, I moved to some of Kay's
other neighbors, let's say I chose the L.
At this point, I would mark it as visited.
If I do a quick check, I can see that this
note I'm at L is also my destination node.
So I must have just found a path between my
source and the destination. So at this point,
if I find my destination, I can just return
true, which was a pattern we spoke about in
a previous problem, the only additional criteria
we need is to mark nodes as visited. That
way, we don't get trapped in an infinite loop.
And that's only going to be needed if we have
cycles in our graph, which if they don't give
us any assumptions we should always guard
against. So let's take a look at another example.
Let's say I had a source of K. And my destination
was Oh, just looking visually in the graph,
you can already see that there's no way to
get from k to O, because they're disconnected,
right, they're on separate islands both step
through the algorithm regardless, so I'm going
to start at K gonna mark it as visited, I'm
going to visit some of Ks neighbors. So I
can move to i, then I can move to J. And then
at this point, I would move back to K and
really make sure they don't explore any of
Ks visited neighbors, so I don't move back
to I right, instead, I should move to an unvisited
neighbor, like l market is visited, then I
only have one other node to visit, which would
be this m node. And at this point, I've actually
exhausted this full graph region, right, there's
nowhere else I can go. And once I finished
my traversal, if I never find my destination
node, then I can just return false, right?
It must be the case that there is no path
that exists from my source node to the destination
node. That's really all there is to this algorithm.
Let's talk about the complexity. If we say
that n is a number of nodes, let's also define
that he is a number of edges. Like we said
previously, this is something typically acceptable
to do for our graph problems. I know that
the time complexity is going to be roughly
of the number of edges. And my space complexity
is going to be O of n that is the number of
nodes. I think it's worth stepping through,
you know what this complexity actually means,
you know, big O refers to the worst case.
So let's think about a worst case graph that
we can have. And there are a few different
graphs that you can kind of design and think
of, I'll just show you one example. So let's
say I was given a graph like this, right?
Notice that although z is kind of on its own
island, all of these nodes that is a three
as well as a C note. They're all members of
the same graph. So let's say I wanted to figure
out is there a path between A and z. So if
I did my traversal algorithm from here, I'll
start at a then I move to B, and then to C,
and then to D, and then to E. At this point,
I've covered all of the edges in the graph.
Remember that the edges are the arrowheads
here, because I have to travel through every
edge of this graph. That's why we said the
time complexity in the worst case is going
to be o of E, right o of the number of edges.
and here we can say the space complexity is
O of n. Because if you're doing this with
either a depth first stack, or a breadth first
queue, in the worst case, you would have to
add everything you visited, or that is all
of the nodes onto your stack or queue. That's
why we say for regular graph traversal algorithms,
we have a time complexity of o v, and a space
complexity of O of n. All right, I think we
have the approach for this algorithm down
pat. At this point, I want to join me in the
walkthrough videos, where we can actually
see how to implement these visited patterns
in some code. I'll see you there. Hey, programmers,
Alan here, right. Now let's go over a JavaScript
solution for this undirected path problem.
So we'll jump right in, just like we said,
in the approach video, there's going to be
a two parter. First, we're going to convert
our edge list into an adjacency list. That
way, it's easier to do a classic traversal
through it. So I'm going to pretend I had
a helper function here. That gives me back
an adjacency list. I'll call it graph. And
I'm going to call this helper function, we'll
say build graph. And if I pass it, just all
of my edges, I want it to do that conversion
for me. So let's work on that helper function
right now. And then we'll jump back to undirected
path. So I'll create my build graph function,
just going to take in the edges, right. And
I know I want my adjacency list to be in the
form of a plain old JavaScript object. So
create that graph object here. And I'm going
to return it by the end just like this. And
what I want to do is fill up this graph with
information from the edges. So I'm going to
iterate through every edge. So for let edge
of edges, so iterating, through every single
edge, I know a single edge would be a pair.
So I'm just gonna de structure out of that,
maybe just my two node identifiers, we'll
call them a and b, from the edge. Nice. What
I want to do is now initialize these nodes
as keys of this graph object. So a would be
something like this, I note or this k node,
right. So what I'll do is check if A is in
my graph, I think really clean up this code,
we better if I check if it's not in the graph.
So if the a node is not in the graph, then
what I can do is initialize it in the graph.
So use it as a key and assign it to be an
empty array. And I'll do the same for B over
here. Right, so I'm initializing A and B in
the graph if they don't exist, and once I
do that, then I can safely just add neighbors
into their their edges, right? So I can say,
the graph square bracket a dot push B. So
now I'm saying that right, B should be a neighbor
of a, but I know that this is an undirected
graph, right? So that should be symmetric.
In other words, then make sure you push a
into the neighbors of B. So it's really important
that you notice that this is an undirected
graph. So your adjacency list needs to be
symmetric in that way. So if a is in B's neighbors,
B should also be an A's neighbors. So that's
looking pretty good. Let's go ahead and see
how that graph looks just with a little little
side test here. So I must steal maybe this
snippet, get that full snippet here, I could
just run it manually love to make sure I can
test these little helper functions before
I use them. So we'll give this a run, we should
just see the adjacency list form of these
edges here. See how it looks. So that looks
pretty good. So I'm seeing that all right,
I is connected to J and K. Right? And that
looks correct based on these edges. Awesome.
And I'm also want to make sure that it's symmetric,
right. So if i and j are over here that I
should have JNI over here as well, right,
it should be a two way street. Alright, now
let's work in our real algorithm here, which
would be some sort of traversal. Now that
you have a nice adjacency list, you can do
either a breadth first or a depth first traversal.
I'm going to implement I think, a depth first.
Typically for me, it's just easier to raise
push if I do it recursively. And so I'm going
to pretend I had a function called has path,
it's going to take in my graph now. And also
a start node and an end node. So I want to
find a path from node A to node B, of course,
I'm going to assume that this function returns
a Boolean. But of course, I have to write
that function for myself. So stay organized
in our code, we'll say has path. I'm going
to take in the graph as well as node A and
node B. And I think a better name for these
arguments as I'm doing this recursively. Let's
call this one source and this one destination.
So over time, we're going to call recursively
and update this source node. And that should
be a familiar pattern to some other problems
resolved. Recently. So think about my base
case. All right, I know that I've has successfully
found a path when my source is equal to my
destination node, if that's the case in return
true, because I just found a path. Otherwise,
I have to keep looking. So I should be able
to look through the neighbors of my source
node. So I could say graph square brackets
source, right? Remember that any point through
this recursion source represents my current
position. If I say graph, square bracket source,
let's say source was I, I'd be accessing all
of ies neighbors, right? So I want to do is
really iterates for let neighbor and, or rather
have graph of source. So if sources I on the
first iteration neighbor would be j, second
iteration neighbor might be K. And for each
of my neighbors, I want to travel to them.
So call has path, you can keep your graph
argument the same needs to change your source
though now you're situated at your neighbor,
and your destination is fixed, or you're always
trying to get to the same exact node. I'm
gonna think about what type this returns I
know this is going to tell me Boolean, right?
True or false? Is there some path from my
neighbor to the destination, I'm going to
check. All right, if that call, returns true,
I'll be explicit here, then I've just found
a path. So just return that true, right, pass
it all the way back up. And kind of the logic
that we form here is, I know that by definition,
source and neighbor are definitely connected.
So there's definitely a path between them.
They're connected by a direct edge. So if
my neighbor has a path to the destination,
then I know, then the source also has a path
to the destination. Awesome. And so after
this for loop is done running, let's say we
never find that any of our neighbors make
a winning path, then means I finished this
for loop without ever returning true, which
means that I can return false right must be
the case that this source node does not have
some path to destination. So I think we can
go ahead and give this code a test run. If
you watch the approach video, you'll notice
that there's something important missing from
this code. But we'll just run it and show
you how to fish here. So here I'm getting
an error edges is not defined what I do horribly
wrong, line 34 months ago, line 34 over here.
So got to take out this call, don't need that
anymore. That's on me. Let's get that test
run. So that was not the error I was expecting.
I am expecting some sort of an infinite loop,
though. Perfect, I'm getting maximum call
stack size exceeded. So I got like an infinite
recursion really. And that's going to occur
because we didn't account for the case where
we have cycles in our graph, right, we need
to avoid that. Because if I have a cycle in
my graph, I'm never going to hit any of these
base cases, I'm just gonna keep traveling
around in a circle. And if that's unclear,
make sure you watch the approach video, right.
And so like we said, the move here is to add
some sort of data that shows where you've
been previously. Typically, the way we do
this for our graph problems is to track some
visited set. So when I make my top level call
to this house path, I know that that is the
actual function that does that traversal,
I'm going to pass along a new argument here.
And I'll make it a new JavaScript set. So
if you're unfamiliar with sets, and JavaScript,
they're really just a collection of items.
And what's really great about a set is in
o of one time, I can add something into the
set. And I can also check for something within
the set is going to be very, very quick for
our traversal. I don't want to use something
slow like an array, because to do a lookup
or a check within an array, that would actually
be O of n time, or it's for a set, it's o
of one. So I'm going to make a new argument
here to receive a column visited. What I want
to do is all right check if my source node
is already in the visited set to do that in
JavaScript I can check visited out has. So
if the source node is inside of the visited
set, then I could return false here, right,
there's no reason to travel through this node
anymore. Because if it's an visited then I
must have traveled at previously. And this
is how I can avoid an infinite recursion can
also move this line downward if I wanted to.
And let's say that I make it through this
if statement. So that means that all right,
this node source has not been visited. But
I'm visiting it right now. So I need to do
visit a dot add source. So this expression
checks if source is in visited, and this expression
adds source to the visited set. I want to
change a few other details here. Make sure
that you pass along the same visited set through
all of your recursive calls over here. Because
you want this visited set to be like global
for the entire traversal right I need to know
exactly where I've been in the past. And once
we have that in place, that should be everything
we need to prevent any any cycles from giving
us infinite recursion here. Let's give it
a test run. Awesome. There's a solution for
our undirected path problem. So important
things to take away here do consider this
problem, a two parter right? phase one is
really straightforward, just converting an
edge list into an adjacency list, which is
actually an important skill to practice. Because
when it comes to, you know, some problems
you'll face in the wild, they are all going
to be basically graph problems. But sometimes
they'll give you the graph and like a different
format, and you can always convert into a
format that you're comfortable with. And from
there, we have a really core pattern of just
doing a traversal through a graph, but also
guarding against infinite loops, right. And
to do that, we just use some sort of a visited
set. Hey, programmers, welcome back right
now want to go over the approach for this
connected components count problem. So in
this problem we want to do is take an adjacency
list representing an undirected graph. As
always, with any graph problem, you want to
start by visualizing the actual graph. And
so if you took a picture of this information,
it would end up looking like a graph with
this structure. The first thing we should
notice about this visual graph is that a has
multiple connected components. So for example,
I can look at this component in pink spanning
just the one and two nodes, I can look at
another component spanning the four or 5678
nodes. And finally, a third component just
covering the three node. And that's why we
say that your result for your function here
should be three, right? Because there are
three different connected components. So let's
come up with an algorithm we can use to count
the components, we know that a general counting
algorithm is going to use some variable, and
we'll initialize that count variable to zero.
And the trick here is to use a combination
of both some standard graph traversal code,
maybe a depth first as well as some iterative
code. So I'll do along the left hand side
is just list out all of my different nodes.
And what I'll do is start by iterating, through
every node of this list. And what I'm going
to do is when I'm currently at some note of
this iterative list, I'm going to start a
traversal at that node. So right now starting
at the node of one, I begin, let's say a depth
first traversal, you can really implement
this pattern using either a depth first or
breadth first. So let's say I start at the
one node over here. What I should do now is
continue this traversal as far as possible,
that's the key to victory here. So from this
one node, I can move to a neighbor of two.
And of course, as I travel through these nodes,
I want to make sure that I mark things as
visited, so I can avoid loops. And marking
things as visited will also ensure that we
don't double count any components here. Once
I hit that to note, I've actually completed
this full component, there's nowhere else
I can explore. So at this point, I should
increment my count by one. So whenever I complete
a new traversal on some region of the graph,
I need to increment my count. At this point,
I now fall back to my iterative code on the
left hand side, and I iterate through the
next node. So I now look at node number two.
If I take a look at node number two, I see
that I already have it marked as visited.
So that means I don't need to start a traversal
at that node. So effectively skip the two
and keep the count the same. next iteration
I have a three, three is unvisited right now.
So I should begin a new traversal starting
at this three node, which means I just mark
it as visited. And since this three is a singleton
node, right, it's not connected to anyone,
I would actually complete their traversal,
just on the three node. At this point, I've
completed a traversal. So I increment my count
by one. So now I have a total count of two,
I fall back to my iterative code. So I moved
from the three node to the four node. And
I see that this four node is unvisited, which
again means I must begin a traversal from
this four node. And I'm going to expand this
traversal. Starting at four as far as I can,
before I go back to my iterative code, right,
so I'm going to explore the six, explore this
five, explore the seven, and finally explore
this eight. At this point, I've completed
a traversal. So I can increment my count up
to three. And then I have to continue and
fall back to my iterative code. So look at
the five node, I see that the five note is
already marked as visited, so I don't start
traversal. And I see that the six node, same
thing don't need to start traversal seven
note already visited, eight nodes already
visited. At this point, I would be done with
the entire algorithm. And there's my final
count of three. So a few interesting mechanics
here, right, you're going to need to definitely
implement some code or some function that
does a traversal through some component as
far as possible, then you also need some iterative
code just to potentially begin a traversal
at every single starting point. And what you
want to do is be sure to mark nodes as visited
as you traverse them, because only when you
marked a new node as visited and complete
that traversal should you increment your count.
You're probably wondering the exact details
of how we implement this in some code, but
don't worry, you'll realize that it's really
just a spin off of our previous graph algorithms
in the walkthrough video, but for now, we
see that n is a number of nodes And he has
a number of edges like usual, we know that
this is really just traversing through the
entire graph. So we can say the time complexity
is just o v, and the space complexity is O
of n, right, depending on whether you do a
breadth first or depth first, you're going
to use that space, then in terms of your stack
or cube. And we can also consider using the
space within our set if you use a set to mark
your nodes as visited, but overall, it still
will lead to a linear time and linear space
solution. Alright, I think I'm ready to code
this one up. I'll see you in the walkthrough
video. Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right,
now let's go over a JavaScript solution for
this connected components count problem. And
so we'll implement exactly the strategy we
spoke about in the approach video. So make
sure you watch that first, we know that this
is going to require really two different mechanisms
are going to need our interactive code just
to hop to different connected components.
And we also need some traversal code to just
explore some single component as far as possible.
And so what I'll do here is let me start with
the iterative code. So I need to begin a traversal
at every potential node. So I can say for
let node of my graph really say in my graph
here, because for this problem we're given
looks like JavaScript objects. So if I say
for let node in graph that would give me each
of these keys like 015, and so on. And so
for every node of the graph, what I want to
do is begin a traversal. So we're going to
assume I have a function here, I'll call it
explore. I'm gonna pass in, of course, the
graph, as well as that node. And what I want
that function to do is do like a, we'll say,
a depth first traversal, from that node as
far as possible, right, so probably going
to need to add more logic into this main function.
But for now, I think it's about time to actually
flesh out explore. So I'll choose to do this
explore method recursively. So we'll define
explore, it's going to take in a graph, as
well as my current node, I'll just call it
current, right. And then from there, I want
to solve this one, using a depth first. So
recursion is fine. And not much to do here,
but really go through my neighbors want to
iterate through every neighbor of this node.
So I can say like neighbor of graph of current,
I recall that graph would be an adjacency
list. So if current is spread this out. So
if current was a node like eight, then on
the first iteration neighbor would be zero,
next iteration neighbor would be five. So
here, I'm just going through all the neighbors
of my current node, I just need to not traverse
to them. So I can call explore, pass along
the same graph, that doesn't change. But now
my new current node would be that neighbor,
just like that, and this will perform the
baseline of just the kind of depth first traversal.
But we need to also mark things as visited,
like we said, in the approach video, that's
a really important a part of the solution.
And I want this like visited set to be global
for my entire traversal. So I'm gonna have
to create it, maybe my main function over
here. So I can create my constant visited,
make it a JavaScript set, because JavaScript
sets off for me O of one lookup, and o of
one addition, I can pass this visited set
my reference until all of these calls over
here. So I know I'm gonna receive visited
over here now. Now I want to actually start
using visited. So a few things to note, right,
I definitely want to use visited to prevent
cycles, right? That's one of the main reasons
we always had visited to our graph traversals.
So some familiar code here. If I've already
visited this node, so if visited, has this
current node, then nothing much to do here,
maybe just return false. Later on, we'll see.
The really cool trick we use here by returning
false, right, actually serves two purposes.
return false because this might be a cycle.
And then I need to make sure that I pass as
visited set along over here as well. Nice.
And let's say that we have a current node
that is not visited. So this statement is
false. Well, then, it seems to be that we're
visiting this node right now. So now we should
add it into the visited set. Nice. And then
beyond that, we need to make sure that our
explorer function is consistent in its type,
right? So I'm going to have my explorer function
do is it's going to return true whenever it
explores like a new node return true. So if
you take a look at this code, for my function
to hit this line 17 return true, then it must
be the case that it has already finished exploring
all of its neighbors, right, because I know
that this for loop does the job of exploring
all of the neighbors, right? So only after
all of those neighbor calls returned. Will
I return true? And that must mean that I've
explored this component as far as possible.
Right? And that seems good to go. And what
I can do is now in my main function, when
I call explore it, now it's going to give
me boolean data, right? If it's exploring
a new island, or a new component, it's going
to return true. So I can check. All right,
if explorer returns true, then that's a new
component. So I can probably increment some
count here, I should have created. So I'll
say 11, counts equals zero, I'm going to increment
that count, when I find a new component and
plus equals one by the end, I should of course,
return that counts. And what you'll notice
is, for scenarios where we, let's say iterate
into a node that we already explored, when
I make this call, I know that that call is
going to return false, because if something's
already explored, it would have been added
to visited. So that's why I'm using some Boolean
return values for this recursive function.
So that code is looking pretty good. I think
at this point, we might be ready to test this
one, let's give it a shot here. So some pretty
tricky codes, not very long. And this is a
really core pattern here. Looks like I'm getting
an error, we have something wrong here. So
looks like the answer should have been two,
but I gave back seven. So I'm counting way
too high. So what I'll do to debug This one
is really just maybe print out my visited.
So this is a very common mistake in JavaScript
want to bring in, I think this example, I
could test it manually. What I want to be
sure to do is maybe at every iteration of,
let's say this this for loop, I console dot
log with visited associate visited changes
every time. And I'll run this manually by
just hitting run. And let's see what we get
here. So a few things to note, it looks like
some of our keys, or some of our items of
the set are strings or the zeros a string.
And other times they're actually numbers,
notice that they're missing quotes, that has
to do with, you know, kind of just JavaScript
objects, technically, keys of a JavaScript
object are going to be always converted as
strings, although the data within these arrays
over here is going to be number. And sets
can actually store both types. And so if you
have like two different types, it's not gonna
be able to figure out like that those really
represent the same node. For example, looking
at this visited set over here, I have like
the number one, as well as the string of one,
which is no good. So let's just convert them
all to maybe strings. So I'll check visited
if it has the string version of my current
node. So I'll just do the conversion for me.
And likewise, I want to add the string version
of the current node over here. That way, I
have very consistent types. So let's run that
manually, again, should just see all of our
strings now. Awesome. And I think we can run
all the test cases. So that's a really important
thing to watch out for in JavaScript. And
JavaScript is pretty unique in that regard.
It just automatically converts all of your
keys into strings. Awesome. All right, programmers,
it's all I got for this connected components
count problem, what you want to do is really
practice this problem. It's actually a very,
very common interview question. And there
are many variations of this problem that we're
going to do in the future. Hey, programmers,
Alvin here, right? Now I want to go over an
approach we can use for this largest component
problem. So in this problem, we're going to
take in a graph, just like we've been doing
as of late. And the first thing you should
probably do is think of this graph as a picture.
So hopefully, you drew it out. So you can
really understand what this is asking. Our
graph information is already given as an adjacency
list. So it's pretty easy to draw out. So
since I have a graph like this, the first
thing I should notice is it could contain
multiple components, right. So here, I kind
of see two separate islands, two separate
components. And I want to consider the sizes
of each respective component. So if I look
at my first component, spanning the nodes,
015, and eight, I know that they have a size
of four, they're the four represents the number
of nodes within that component. So I'm really
interested in a number of nodes have a component,
not necessarily the number of edges. If I
look at the other component that spans the
nodes, two, three, and four, that definitely
has a node group of three. And this problem
really cares about the largest component,
so I should just return four, because it's
the largest component size. So when it comes
to what this question is asking, you do have
some familiar patterns if you've been following
these problems in order and of course, I always
recommend that you do these problems in order.
So how can we go about solving this one? Well,
I know I'm gonna need some sort of iterative
code that way I can travel and hop to different
components or different islands, I can probably
do some depth first traversal variation that
also finds the size of a connected component.
So let's step through how this algorithm might
run. On the side. I'm going to list out my
nodes to represent how I'm going to do the
iterations to be In a traversal at every node
as my starting point, so I'm going to start
at node zero. And since node zero is unvisited
right, now, I'm going to begin a brand new
traversal, starting at node zero. And I'm
going to mark my nodes as visited as I go,
because like usual for our undirected graphs,
you want to watch out and prevent any cycles
that you may get trapped in. And I know that
this depth first traversal, is going to explore
this full region as far as possible. And by
the power of recursion, it'll be pretty easy
to implement some pattern that can count every
node as we traverse through it. So I'm going
to treat each of these nodes as just being
a single note, of course. And eventually,
those ones are going to return to my top level
call, in which case, I can add them all up,
getting me a grand total of four. If this
feels very hand wavy, and you're wondering,
like how the heck are we going to code up
that pattern, don't worry, it's actually a
pattern we've seen before. And so I'll cover
that in detail in the code. Just know for
now, it's actually not a big deal to get the
count of nodes, right. So now that I know
that the size of this component is four, what
I should do is I guess store it as my current
largest island or component I've seen so far,
because it's the first component that I've
considered. At this point, I should fall back
to my intuitive code. So I look at the node
of one, what I should notice is this node
one is already checked off, it's already visited.
So there's no reason to start another traversal
from this node, because if it's visited, that
means I have already explored the component
that node one is a member of, so I can basically
skip it, go on to node two in my iteration,
since node two is unvisited, I should begin
a new traversal. Over here, I know that this
depth first traversal is going to explore
that component as far as possible, it's going
to go ahead and count all of those nodes as
one. And eventually some of those counts together,
giving me a count of three. And so this next
component has a size of three, I need to compare
that three against my current largest four,
obviously, the four is bigger, so the four
gets to stay as the largest. When I fall back
to my iterative code, I get to my note of
three threes already visited, so no reason
to start anew. traversal, four is already
visited, so nothing to do, five is visited.
And of course, eight is visited as well. At
this point, we're done looking at every single
node within our graph, and we must have explored
every single component, so we can just return
the final value that we have stored in that
largest variable. Awesome. When it comes to
the complexity of this algorithm, it's pretty
straightforward. It's basically exactly all
of the algorithms we've seen so far, we see
that n is the number of nodes and e is a number
of edges, we know that the time complexity
is going to be roughly o of the number of
edges really just exploring through the entire
graph, we can also see that the space complexity
is also going to be linear, really just O
of n. Because through all of this, we're probably
going to be storing all of our nodes in a
set right to track visited. And depending
on how you implement your traversal algorithm,
whether you use depth first or breadth first,
you're also going to use a linear amount of
space through your stack or your queue. So
overall, we're looking at a very efficient,
linear solution. And so with that, I think
I'm ready to code this one up. What I want
you to do though, first is possibly give this
one a shot on your own first cluster, really
just utilizing some code that we've seen in
the past. So give it a go on your own. If
you get stuck, you can find me in the walkthrough
video. I'll see you there. Hey, programmers,
Alvin here, right now let's go over a JavaScript
solution for this largest component problem.
So this problem is going to be really just
a spin off of our last problem. So we'll hop
right into it. And as always, make sure you
watch the approach video first. And we'll
start by building our code that will help
us start a traversal on disconnected islands
here, right? This is connected components,
we should say. And so I'll start my iterating
through every node of the graph, that means
I just iterate through the keys of my input
object here. Because remember, we're given
this graph as already an adjacency list. So
I can say for let node in the graph. So I'll
give me the nodes like 015, and so on. And
what I'll do is I'm going to start a traversal
here, right? So we're going to pretend I had
a function, I'll call it explore size. And
if I give it the graph information, as well
as the node that I want to traverse through,
hopefully, it actually does a traversal through
that entire connected component, right. And
what I'm going to assume is, let me assume
that this function actually returns the size
of that entire component. So that would be
a number right, representing the number of
nodes in that component. And so if I have
that should receive it here, call it size.
And I know I need some like max value logic
for this entire for loop. So I'm going to
create longest, initialize it to zero. And
then from there, I can check. All right, if
the size of the component I just found, if
it's bigger than the longest, then I can replace
the longest simply longest equals size, that
after the for loop, I would just read Turn
the longest course I need to write this explore
size function. So I'll implement this as a
type of depth first. So I'm going to make
it recursive, as for size, taking the graph,
as well as our current node. And a few things
I should watch out for here, they tell us
that we have an undirected graph. And so we
need to make sure that we avoid any cycles.
So we're also set up here is some classic
structure, I'm going to use a visited set,
we're going to use a set because it gives
me O of one lookup and o of one insertion.
So now that I have my visited set, I can pass
it along, as I start the traversals. And now
let's work on a base case, as well do to get
going is check if I visited this node already.
So if the visited set already has this current
node that I need to return, basically avoid
a recursive call. But I also want a consistent
type here, right, so I'm assuming that this
function gives back a number representing
the size at some point in my traversal. If
I get to a node that has already been visited,
that means I counted it already. And so I'll
treat it as zero right now, because I don't
want to double count my nodes, right otherwise
would be inaccurate here. And now beyond that,
what I can do is maybe create a variable here,
I'll call it size, I'm going to set that equal
to one to represent the current node I'm on
right now, right? If this condition is not
true, then it's the first time I'm seeing
this node, so I need to count it. And we'll
also be sure to do is add it to visited that
way I don't get into a cycle into the node
later on. Nice. And at this point, I need
to make my recursive call on the neighbors
of this node. So like we usually do could
say for let neighbor of graph of node. So
remember your shape of data here. So if node
was a key, like five, when I say, Neighbor
of graph node, that would iterate through
the neighbors a five, zero, and then eight,
and so on. And so here, I make my recursive
calls, I'm gonna call the same function explore
sighs, pass along the same graph. But now
you're situated at your neighbor, and you
can provide the same visited set. And here's
where I do my recursive leap of faith, right,
I'm going to assume that this explore size
function is working. So if it was working,
what would it give back, it would give me
back a number representing the size of that
graph, right beginning at my neighbor. So
whatever number I get back here, I just want
to increment my size by that, right. And that
would accumulate a basically a count of all
of the nodes in this fully connected component.
And after I'm done exploring my neighbors,
I would have explored the entire component
fully. So I can just return my final answer,
which would just be the size over here, really
important thing you need to do is make sure
if you follow this kind of strategy, you start
your size equal to one, and you add to it
over time, because this one represents the
current node that I'm at, I know that every
call is going to count its own node. So over
time, this will actually accumulate everything
I need. So feels pretty good, have our nice
visited logic. And we already wrote our main
function here. Notice how we're splitting
up this code in a nice little helper function
here, I think it's the best way to express
this, it's very similar to some previous problems
that we've done. Right, I think at this point,
let's go ahead and give this a shot. See,
what we get, should be able to put it through
a few different test cases. Nice. And there,
we have the largest component to problem.
So a few things, I want to draw your eye to
remember that for your graph problems, or
you have disconnected components, you're going
to need not only your traversal code, but
some just iterative mechanism, usually just
a loop to make sure you can hop to different
components, right? Because if you only had
your regular like traversal function, by definition,
there is no edge between separate components.
So you would never be able to explore the
full graph. Otherwise, alright, programmers
practices, and I'll catch you in the next
one. Hey, programmers, Alvin here, right.
Now let's go over an approach we can use for
the shortest path problem. So here we have
another graph problem, and your graph is going
to be given as an edge list. So the first
thing we should probably do is, of course,
visualize this graph. And in the context of
your code, it probably would be best if you
convert it into an adjacency list. Since we've
seen that pattern a few times in some recent
problems. I'll leave that part to you. But
we're going to end up with a graph that looks
like this. And in this problem, we're also
going to be given a two nodes here, let's
say W and z, what I want to do is return the
smallest path between these two nodes. And
here I have two obvious paths, right? One
way I can get from W to z would be to go through
x and y. And there I can see that that path
length would be three. Do note here that we're
going to consider the path link as the number
of edges within the path. So not the number
of nodes, right? So that means how do I calculate
three here? What's really just three lines,
right, three edges. That's one way to get
from WC another obvious way to get from W
to z would be to go through VI, which case,
I would only need to use two edges. So that
path line is of course two. And this problem,
what I want to do is return the smallest possible
path length. So I should return the final
answer of two here. So we know that this problem
is going to require us to do a graph pathfinding
algorithm. The question is, which one should
we take, we either can choose, of course,
a depth first traversal, or a breadth first
traversal, I'll cut to the chase here. And
both of them would actually give you a strategy
that works, meaning you can solve this with
either a depth first or a breadth first strategy.
But maybe one of these algorithms would be
better than the other. So let's consider the
possibilities. So let's say I had some large
graph, well think abstractly right now. So
kind of just looking at an abstract example.
And let's say I was stepping through some
depth first traversal. Let me say I have my
starting node in yellow, and I'll have my
target node in blue. So what I want to do
is, again, figure out what's the minimum path
distance between these two nodes, obviously,
you know, just in the long run, you should
get an answer like two here, right, because
two is definitely the shortest path between
these two nodes. If we did a depth first traversal,
I know that depth first would force me to
look in one direction as far as possible,
until I have to switch directions, right.
So for my starting on yellow, let's say we
move to the right, that'd be one edge and
move to the right again, two edges move to
the right, again, three edges. At this point,
I can't move right anymore. So let's say you
move downward, so at 456 have to switch directions,
again, seven, eight. And at this point, we
kind of already see that this is going to
end up possibly getting to the blue target
node. But that wouldn't be the shortest path.
Something unfortunate here is although my
star and nodes are really close together,
a depth first traversal could be unlucky in
that it may search in a totally wrong direction,
and snake all the way through the graph until
it eventually finds my target node, at which
point I definitely don't have the shortest
path. So I think a breadth first traversal
is going to be more useful here. So let's
say start at my green node, still my same
starting point. And if I did a breadth first
traversal, I know that breadth first means
I'm going to explore all the directions very
evenly. So it would look like this. So I would
explore all nodes one edge away from my starting
point. And then from there, I would begin
to explore all nodes two edges away from my
starting point. And at some point, I'm going
to hit my target node. And if it's the first
time I'm seeing my target node, then by definition,
I must have just found the shortest path,
right, the shortest path would just be two.
So that's my high level argument for why a
breadth first search is going to be more useful,
in my opinion, for this problem, let's step
through this process a little more algorithmically.
So let's say I had my original graph. And
if I'm gonna do a breadth first traversal,
I know that I have to use a queue right no
matter what a queue is what gives you that
breadth first order. And what I'll do is eyes
the items of my queue, I'm going to store
not only the nodes, but also the distance
from my starting point, that means I'm going
to initialize my starting note on the queue
along with the distance of zero. And that
represents the fact that all right, that note
of W is zero edges away from the starting
point, because it itself is the starting point.
So at any point in time, the items of my queue
are always going to be pairs, right of node
comma distance. So now we're going to begin
our general algorithm, I'm going to keep iterating.
While my queue is not empty, a single iteration
of breathless would remove the front end of
my queue, and I'll label it as my current
node. At this point, I should check Alright,
is my current node of W, the thing I'm looking
for? It's not, so I need to explore W's neighbors.
So I can look at the x node. And I know I
need to add it into my queue. But when I add
it into my queue, I want to make sure I tag
it with a distance. So if my current node
has this zero, I know that a neighbor of this
node would have distance one, so I just increment
the current distance by one. So onto my queue,
I put an item that says x comma one. And I
have a similar scenario for this V node. It's
also a neighbor of W. And so I put v comma
one on my queue as well. At this point, I
can go to my next iteration, or move the front
of my queue. So I look at the x. And then
I look at X's neighbors do bear in mind that
because I have an undirected graph here, x
really has two neighbors, right, it has w
as a neighbor, as well as y. So something
you should already know is I need to track
visited. In other words, when x is going to
consider its neighbors, it should really only
care about the Y, right, I don't want X to
put w back on the queue, because then I would
get an infinite cycle. So I'm just gonna look
at the Y over here. I'm going to add it to
my queue. Because I know my current note of
X has a distance of one y must have a distance
of two always just incrementing the distance
by one. Cool. And then I carry on with this
algorithm. I removed the front of my queue
now, which would be the V note. And at this
point, I can consider V's neighbors, and I
do See that one of its neighbors is actually
the Xena, that's the only unvisited neighbor,
I'm going to be sure to add z into my queue
and tag it with a distance of two, right,
because if my v has distance one, its neighbor
would have a distance of one grader. At this
point, you can already see how this algorithm
is going to work out. Eventually, this z nodes
going to leave the queue, and that would actually
be my target node. So since I've added a node
into the queue that matches my target, I know
I have my final answer. The two here does
represent the number of edges we took in that
logical path. And I would, of course, just
return that too. So for the most part, this
algorithm just sounds like a classic breadth
first traversal. Using a queue on a graph,
the only interesting bit is now we're also
going to track the current distance. You know,
when it comes to counting the length of a
path, you need some counting mechanism. And
so if you begin your queue with your starting
node with a distance of zero, every time something
leaves a cube, and adds its neighbors, it
should increment that distance by one. And
like you already guessed, this algorithm is
pretty efficient, because we don't have to
traverse through the graph more than one.
So we'll see that this has a linear complexity.
Alright, I think I have everything I need
to code up this one, I'm sure you're wondering
about these implementation details. So what
you want to do is possibly give this implementation
a shot on your own. And if you need some help,
you can find me in those walkthrough videos.
See you there. Hey, programmers, Alan here,
right. Now let's go over a JavaScript solution
for the shortest path problem. So we'll jump
right in, hopefully, you watch the approach
video. And so we'll start by converting our
edge list input into something more useful
for our traversal like an adjacency list,
we're going to write a very classic function.
When I call it build graph, like you expect
it takes in the edges. And I want it to return
an adjacency list. For me, that means a JavaScript
object, I'll call it graph, by the end of
this function, this will help I'm going to
return the graph and some common code, I'm
going to iterate through every pair, right,
basically every edge, I'll say, for left edge
of edges. As I'm iterating, through every
edge, when I want to do is unpack that edge
into its component nodes, I'll call it a and
b. And now I can start formatting my adjacency
list. So I know I want the keys of this graph
to be obviously the nodes, I want the values
to be an array of the neighbors of that node.
So what I'll do is, it's the first time encountering
a node, I'll check. Alright, if this a node
if it's not in the graph yet as a key, then
I should create it for the first time. So
use it as a key and initialize its value to
an empty array, basically, at the start is
going to have no neighbors. Likewise for B.
And then, at this point, I know that A and
B now definitely exist as keys within the
graph. And so I just want to add those neighbors.
So if I have an edge, like w comma x, I know
x is a neighbor of w, and w is a neighbor
of x. So simply put in say, graph a dot push
B, and then just the inverse of that should
be good to go. Cool. So that should give us
our graph. Let's go ahead and use that in
our main function now. So we'll just say graph
equals build graph on the edges. And what
we want to do now is actually work in our
breadth first logic, like we said from the
approach video. So a few things I'm going
to do, I'm going to definitely set up my queue,
we said that the key to victory here was to
not only store the node in your queue, but
for every like frame inside of your queue
also store its distance from node A. So I'll
just use like a pair of things. So the elements
of my queue are going to be always a pair.
And I'll throw on the initial node A, and
also the number zero, because at the start,
right, this node A is zero edges away from
itself. So that's good to go. And over time,
I'm going to be incrementing. This number,
it seems nice. And so let's keep on keepin
on here. All right, a while loop, classic
condition would be all right, while your queue
is not empty, then I shall remove something
from the queue. So always remove from the
front if you want to follow a true breadth
first order. So I can do do dot shift. And
that will give me back an array or give me
back one of these sub arrays here. I know
it's always going to be a pair so I can just
unpack. And I'll just say alright, grab the
current node as well as the distance. Nice.
I'm going to check the node here that I just
removed from the queue. If that node is node
B, that I must have just found a path and
I know the distance in that path, I can just
return it. But if this condition is not true,
then I need to keep searching through my graph.
Since that means I need to add this nodes
neighbors to the back of the queue. So I'm
going to iterate remember that we have adjacency
lists the entire time. So I'm going to say,
for, let's say, Neighbor of graph of node.
So get all the neighbors of this node. And
what I'll do is just add those neighbors into
my queue. So q dot push, neighbor, try to
remember what the form of our graph is over
here. Maybe as a quick little spot check,
make sure on the same page, let me just console
dot log, the adjacency lists, let's say we
took this example manually, just paste it
down below. And I'll just give it nice little
manual runs, I'm not running the test cases
quite yet. So we converted this edge list
into this adjacency list, right. And when
we say no to something like W, when we say
graph, square bracket, no, that would give
us this array, co authored sorters, iterating,
through all the neighbors of this node and
adding them to the queue, one thing we should
watch out for is when we push things back
onto the queue, we want to maintain the same
format. So I actually still want to maintain
pairs. So I'll make the first element of the
pair, the neighboring node on the second element
needs to be the distance. And since it's a
neighbor, its distance would be plus one over
here. So that's how I'm growing and counting
the distance. So let's give this a test run.
There are a few things we need to work on
still, though. But we'll pass a few of these
examples, at least until we timeout on a particular
example. One thing this code is missing is
any cycle prevention, right? I know that it's
going to be a very common scenario, because
I have an undirected graph, right. And so
what I'll be sure to do is maintain a visited
set, sort of pattern that you're used to,
we're just gonna implemented for our iterative,
breathless right now. So start out with a
set. And when you do this iteratively, the
move would be to make sure that if something
is added to the queue, it should also be marked
as visited. So if I initialize my queue with
node A, then I also want to initialize my
visited set with node A, just like so. So
if you're unfamiliar with the set constructor
in JavaScript, if you want to initialize it
with some values, you actually have to pass
in an array containing those values. So the
values of my visited set are just going to
be the nodes write the node IDs. Cool. And
then I want to work that logic into my while
loop. And so whenever I'm about to add something
into the queue, that is, I'm going to add
a neighbor into the queue, first check if
that neighbor is not visited yet, so only
if not visited has neighbor. Right, so only
if this neighbor has not yet been visited,
then I should add it to my queue. And if I'm
about to add it to the queue, like we just
said anything that interest, the queue should
immediately be marked as visited. So here
I'll say visited, add, the neighbor net should
avoid adding any particular node more than
once into the queue, avoiding any cycles.
Awesome. So that feels pretty good. Let's
give that a test run. Now. We hope to not
timeout at least, all that same example, we're
actually returning undefined where we expect
negative one. So if you look at the actual
prompt, they tell us that, alright, if you
can't find a path between A and B, then you
should return negative one. Let's look at
an example or test 04. And you kind of drew
it out, you would see that there would be
no such path that connects B to G. The reason
we're returning undefined right now is we're
gonna finish our traversal mean, meaning our
queue is going to empty out. And then we're
just going to hit the end of this function.
And if I don't hit a return line by default
in JavaScript, I'm going to get undefined.
So we know if we finish the while loop, and
we never found node B, then we can just return
negative one, that must mean that there is
no such path that connects a to b. So let's
give this a test run. Now. This should be
our final version of our shortest path algorithm.
Awesome. So be sure to practice this algorithm
before you move on. And do make sure that
you understand the choice of breadth first
here over depth first, for most of your basic
just graph problems that require you to calculate
a shortest path path meaning just the number
of edges. Typically, you'll find breadth first
easiest way to calculate that hey programmers,
Alvin here, right now let's go over to the
approach for this island count problem. So
in this problem, we're going to be given a
2d array representing a grid of land and waters
here we have l characters representing land,
and W characters representing water. Let's
try to visualize this. In this problem we
want to do is return a number representing
the number of islands on the grid. We're going
to consider an island as a vertical or horizontal
connected region of land. So in this particular
example, we should return four. Because there
are four different islands, we can label them
as such, this is going to be any type of problems
for us. And we should really think about it
as if we have a graph, I'm going to refer
to these style problems as a grid graph. And
so although we're not given any explicit like
nodes and edges, I can still think about positions
of this graph as nodes. So for example, let's
consider the indices here. So I have my row
indices along the left hand side, and my column
indices along the top. And I can designate
any position of this grid using a pair of
row and column. So for example, if I looked
at position three comma four, that would be
this position over here. And what I should
do is mentally think about a position as if
it's a node. And if I met some node, I do
have some potential neighbors. given any position
of the spread, I have at most four neighbors
in the up down left and right directions.
given any position of the grid, it's really
easy to determine what our potential neighbors
are, it's really just a matter of adding or
subtracting one from either the row or the
column. Let's generalize this formula. So
let's say I was at some position, we'll call
it our see, if I want it to go upward, that
would mean you decrement, the row by one,
keep the column the same. If you went down,
that would mean increasing the row by one,
if you went to the right, that would be increasing
the column by one. And if you want to go left,
then you should just decrease the column by
one, do bear in mind that the top left position
of our grid is going to be 00. And that's
why we have this type of arithmetic rule.
So now that we're starting to frame this grid
problem, as if it's a graph, we can use some
common patterns, I know that this problem
is really asked me to count the number of
connected components or the number of islands
on this grid. So I'm going to need some iterative
code, probably some nested loops to just iterate
through every potential Island and start some
traversal at that island. So when it comes
to our iterative code, we just want nested
loops to iterate through every row column.
That means the iterations should look something
like this, just moving left to right. until
we finish around which case we can go to the
next row. Let's actually iron out the main
logic that we need in our algorithm. So let's
say we start or nested loops from the very
beginning, what I do is check my current position,
what I want to do is check if my current position
is land right now it's water, so I can just
continue. On the next iteration, I do have
some land position. And since I'm on a piece
of land, right now, what I want to do is explore
this land region as far as possible, probably
using some depth first traversal. And do bear
in mind, like most of our undirected graph
problems, we're going to need to be sure to
mark things as visited, so we don't get trapped
in any infinite cycles. So for example, if
I started a traversal, at this position, I
can go downward. But I can also go upward
from here. And I can bounce back between the
two going up and down, giving me an infinite
cycle. So we know how to fix this using all
of our graph mechanics, right, just use a
visited set. So if I do a depth first traversal,
starting at this position, I know I'm going
to mark off all of these land pieces as visited.
And what I also want to do is make sure that
I increments accounts, representing the fact
that I've just explored some new island fully.
So right now, my count zero, since I just
finished exploring something now my count
is one. And at this point, I can fall back
to my iterative code to scan for another island.
So I move to the right, it's water. So continue,
water continue. Now I have another island.
And again, I just do some depth first traversal
through it. And of course I increment my count.
This pattern will follow right? Eventually,
when I hit the new row, I could be at a land
position. But I should also make sure that
this land position is unexplored, right. So
since I'm at position one, comma zero, and
this land has already been explored, I don't
need to begin a depth first traversal. And
I also don't need to begin a traversal here.
And this continues, avoiding starting a traversal.
Wherever I have a visited piece of land, we
know eventually, we're going to hit a new
island like this one, where I have a piece
of land that is unvisited. So at that point,
that's my criteria for starting a new depth
first traversal, I explore this region, increment
my count, and continue business as usual until
I hit this final island that is unvisited.
And so I visit it and increment my count.
And by the end of my iterations, I should
have my final count of four. So that logic
is actually pretty straightforward, just a
variation of our classic connected component,
counting logic, except now we're adjusting
the criteria we use for looking at neighbors,
right, our neighbors are actually going to
just be either above downward to the left
or to the right of our current position. We
talked about the complexity of this algorithm,
we should consider the size of the input and
the fact that it has two dimensions, right?
So if I say that R is a number of rows, and
C is a number of columns, well and the iterative
codes pretty straightforward, I know that's
going to give me r times C iterations. And
if I also consider any potential in depth
first traversal I do starting at some land.
In the worst case, I could have one Giant
Island, which is also going to be our time
to see. So the overall complexity, it's just
going to be our time See, the space complexity
for very similar reason is our time see, because
imagine that we mark all of these positions
as visited, that probably means we'd have
to add them to some set. Right, so we have
our time see different positions. And by the
end, I could add each and every one of them
into my set, the space complexity of our time.
See also includes any traversal related data
structures like stacks, or queues, depending
on how you implement this one. So overall,
this is going to be a very efficient solution
to solve this one, what you should do is probably
give it a shot on your own first, if you get
stuck, you can find me in the walkthrough
videos. I'll see you there. Hey, programmers,
Alvin here, right now, let's go over a JavaScript
walkthrough for this island count problem.
So as always, make sure you watch the approach
video first. And we'll jump right in. So we
know that this is really just a spin off of
our kind of graph connected components problems,
except now we have a grid graph, right? I
can still think about like this grid as if
it's a graph, because if I think about any
particular position of this grid, I know I
have some neighboring positions that I can
travel through mainly, my four neighbors Up,
down, left and right for me, let me start
my laying down some iterative code that can
begin a traversal at every node or every position
of this grid. That way, I can start considering
different islands, right. So I'm going to
use just a for loop for this, I'm going to
iterate through every possible row column
combinations every position. So I'll say R
equals zero, iterate up to the length of the
grid, so grid dot length to our plus equals
one, and do something very similar for my
columns nested inside, right? Watch out for
some details here though, looking at the examples,
we can't actually assume that we're always
get a square shaped grid square meaning like
as if the number of rows was the same as the
number of columns, because sometimes I'll
have like an asymmetric grid occasionally,
right? If I look at this very first one, it
looks like the width is going to be five here,
but the height is six. So separately for the
columns, I want to reference the column lines
over here. So we're gonna say grid, zero length.
Nice. And so at this point, I have some row
composition, I want to begin a traversal,
let's say a depth first traversal at that
position. So here's where I invoke some like
helper function, that will make it a little
bit, I'll call it explore. And what's going
to do is, of course, taking the grid information,
as well as the row column I want to traverse
through nice. And at this point, I think we'll
actually hop to building this this helper
function, then we probably need to fill out
some more logic within our main driver function
here. So let's bake this explore helper function.
So taking the grid and your row column, and
something I should also consider is because
I know that this is really a type of graph
problem, right? I want to prevent infinite
cycles, right? So consider this, let's say
I was somewhere in the middle of my traversal,
let's say I was at this piece of land, I know
that this piece of land is going to travel
through its right neighbor. And it could be
the case that this piece of land now travels
its left neighbor, so I go left and then right
and then left and right. Now it gives me an
infinite loop, right. So whenever you have
this notion of like undirected graph or undirected
connections, then always guard with a visited
set. We've seen this pattern before. So maybe
up top globally, for the entire traversal,
I'll create a visited set. So in JavaScript,
just a new set, you're probably wondering,
you know, what am I going to make the members
of this set? Well, I need to designate positions,
right? Think about it as if positions are
like the nodes in this grid in this graph,
right. And so what I'll do is pass along this
visit set, so I can accept it as an org over
here. And when it comes to using your visited
set, what you want to do is make sure you
combine your row and column because together
they designate your actual position. I think
this is actually worth going through specifically
more of like a language thing in JavaScript,
compared to other programming languages. So
quick aside over here, let me get myself some
more room might be a while. Because if you're
unfamiliar with sets, and you don't kind of
know, their nuances, might actually hit you
in the butt later on. So let's say I had a
set so I'll create an offset. So can you set
and let's say I added I don't know, like an
array containing a row column position. So
I'm gonna say is, alright, maybe I had position,
I don't know, one comma three. And I added
that into my set. So I do s dot add that position.
This is actually a common gotcha in JavaScript.
If you put any like reference types, like
an array or like an object into your set,
it's actually going to check for reference
equality when you check for existence later
on. In other words, now I can't really do
console dot log s dot has one three, because
this array literal is technically a different
array in memory. So I wish I could get like
true back in this scenario, but I'm not going
to get a true. So we'll just run that manually
see what we get. So like, we say, we're gonna
get a false here, which is not so good. So
instead, your Fix would be to actually convert
this into some string data. So instead, maybe
write as if you had one comma three, because
strings are primitive types, and I would actually
be able to store that string. So whenever
I say the string literal, this would actually
give me a match now, so I should get a nice
true here. Awesome. So we'll want to use that
pattern to our advantage. And so maybe I'll
start by creating some position variable,
that's going to be like the string of FIDE
a version of our position. So just take my
row, maybe add a comma, and also put the column
here. Nice. And the reason I want to comma
separate is, I need to have different bounds
for my row and column. In other words, imagine
I had a row of let's say, 12. And I had a
column of four. If I turn that into a key,
or a position, that would give me position
as looks like 12, comma for another scenario,
let's say I had row one, and then column 24,
that would give me a position of this right?
one comma 24. Right, it's really important
that you put a comma to separate your row
and column positions, because imagine, I didn't
put the comma, then it would have a collision
here, I have two totally distinct positions,
right? 12, four, and 124. And if I don't put
a comma, they look like they have the same
position key. So that's why I need to comma
separate them. Common gotcha there. But now
that I have this position, I can use it to
my advantage in this visited set. So if I've
already visited this position, so if my visited
has this position, then I should exit, right,
I need to return something. And I want this
explorer function do something similar, like
we've done in our old component problems,
I want it to return a Boolean indicating whether
or not this is a new island that I'm exploring.
So if it's visited already, that's definitely
not new, right. So just return false, meaning
it's not a new island. If I make it past this
if statement, in other words, if position
is not in visited, that I need to mark it
as visited right now, second, do visited,
add this position. So now I have my core like
cycle prevention logic. Beyond that, I have
a few other scenarios, we know that in our
traversal, we're going to look at our different
like neighbors. And so what I want to do is
make sure that I'm in bounds here. So I'm
going to check, like to split this up into
variables, I'll say, one, a boolean variable
called row in bounds. And I'll do is just
check if zero is less than or equal to the
row. And that row is strictly less than will
say, the length of my grid. So I'm just checking
to see if my opposition is in bounds here,
I do a quick check, I need to be inclusive
with zero because zero is a totally valid
index, right? I need to be exclusive with
the length because imagine I had a grid with
length five, it's last valid index is four.
So I need to be strictly less than here. And
I'll write a similar variable for my column
in bounds, just like this. And at this point,
I can write a nice semantic if statement check,
all right, if your row is not in bounds, or
your column is not in bounds, then exit, right?
So return like before I can return false,
right? Because I should not consider like
an invalid position and a balanced position
as an island, right? So that's looking good.
Final base case I need though is, what if
my current position is water, right? I only
want to do my traversal through land. And
so I'll add another statement for that. So
up here, I can check. All right, if my grid
at row column, if it's equal to water, then
also return false. No reason to count it,
it's really important that you put this in
bounds check before you index into your grid,
right? Because imagine that your row and column
were out of bounds. If you write line 15 like
this, immediately, you're going to get an
out of bounds error. So start with your guard
to check if you're in bounds if you want it
to because most of these conditionals they
all return false have the same consequence.
You can probably or them together. Typically
I like to keep them separate. That way I always
remember to write them typically for like
your grid graph problems. This is very canonical
code. Alright, so if I make it past all of
these base cases, and I have the recursive
case, so I must be at an unvisited piece of
land. And when I want to do is do my depth
first traversal, right. So here's where I
explore my neighbors and I have four neighbors.
If I wanted to go above that I decrement,
my row by one, keep the column the same, pass
along the same visited, because remember,
we have like the array indices here. So this
is row zero, this is row one. So we'll lower
row numbers mean upward, in the same way,
lower column numbers mean to the left. So
this is up, this is down by do just minus
one over here, that would be to the left,
then plus one on the column would be to the
right. Cool, and I can keep this code very
flat as it is something that I'm a huge proponent
of when you write recursion, for the most
part, I always try to make sure that I don't
look before I leap. In other words, just from
this logic alone, it couldn't be the case
that row minus one is out of bounds. But that's
okay. Because if it's out of bounds, when
I evaluate this call, it's going to immediately
be caught by this base case, right. And if
I express my logic like this, if I don't look,
before I leave, if I just leap and then catch
myself with the base case, you don't have
to write repetitive code. In other words,
some people write code like this, where it's
like, Alright, if row minus one inbounds kind
of using pseudocode. Here, they would have
to write row plus one inbounds. And you would
have to write a guarding if statement around
every recursive call, instead, just write
one base case. And you can catch all of these
different out of bounds, right. So that's
why I prefer it this way. And so I know that
by the time I return out of these recursive
calls, I'm back at this segment of my code.
And what I can do is return true because I
must be finished with that traversal. And
the reason I'm returning true is true symbolizes
that I've just finished exploring a brand
new island, so I need to count it. Nice. It's
also consistent with the data type, I have
Boolean for this explore function. So for
the most part, this looks like really just
a spin off of our previous like graph, depth
first code. And now I want to use that boolean
data in my main function here. So here's where
I can actually count my islands. So guess
I really need some logic here that says initialize
some counts equal to zero. And whenever you
find a new island, increment that count. So
if I just have found a new island, we're going
to get back true from this this call, right?
Because remember that I'm beginning a traversal,
starting at this row column position. So if
it gives me back true, then I can totally
increment my count by one. Notice that whenever
I begin a traversal on a position I've seen
before, it would have been added to visited
before. So I would return via this if statement
on line 21, I return false. If I return false,
then I don't double count that island. So
I do need a combination of both iterative
code to potentially leap to different islands.
But I can use a visited set to prevent myself
from double counting any particular Island.
So this is looking pretty good. Let's not
forget to of course, return our counts at
the end. Let's give this a run. This will
probably be the first in a series of these
like grid graph problems. Really try to understand
how we can think about still a grid as if
it's a graph, right? We just have different
rules for how we look at our neighbors. Right?
Now, a node is really a position and its neighbors
are its four neighbors Up, down, left and
right. Alright programmers, I want you to
practice this pattern because we're going
to see it in the next few problems. I'll leave
it to you see in the next one. Hey, programmers
outlane here, right now let's go over an approach
for this minimum Island problem. So we're
going to be given here a grid containing a
water inland really just some characters inside
of our grid. So of course, as always, let's
visualize this. And what I want to do in this
problem is return a number representing the
minimum Island size, we're going to consider
an island, a connected region of vertical
or horizontally connected pieces of land.
So for this particular input, our answer should
be to looking at our grid, I have three separate
islands. And they all have different sizes,
right? sizes, a four, two and five, I just
choose the smallest of the islands. So that
would be the two over here. So how can I actually
come up with a strategy for this one, you
should already know that this is just a spin
off of our previous a grid graph problem,
where instead of doing just a count of the
number of islands, now I want to find the
sizes of islands. I know to actually look
at different islands, I'm gonna need some
nested code, but I'm also gonna need some
depth first traversal code to explore a single
Island. So overall, this should be a pretty
classic strategy for us. So let's say we start
attacking this we know we're going to begin
our nested loops in the top left corner And
if our current position is water, then we
actually don't need to do anything. next iteration,
I have some land. At this point, I could begin
on my depth first traversal. And I know that
I should be marking things as visited to avoid
any infinite loops, right. So by the time
this traversal completes, I'm going to mark
all of these guys as visited. But I also wanted
to determine the size of this entire island
region. So every time I get a position that
is land, I should treat it as one. And then
when it comes to how I implement on my traversal,
I can just gather up these ones, right, just
add them all up. So that would look something
like this. And for my top level call for that
traversal, I should get an island size of
four. And so if that kind of traversal algorithm,
especially how we compute the size of the
island, is pretty hand wavy, don't worry that
when we actually go through the code walkthrough,
it's just a matter of some recursion, and
some recursion we've actually seen before
in past problems of the course. But any case,
now that I have this island size of four,
it's actually the first island that I've seen.
And so I'm going to consider it the mid size
so far. But I need to keep looking in case
something is smaller. So move to the right.
So if it's water, I do nothing, water again,
do nothing. Now I have another islands, I
begin my traversal market these as visited.
And when I find the size of this island, of
course, it's going to give me two, I compare
that to to my current mid size two is smaller,
so I store two as the mid size so far. And
we just continue business as usual. Note that
when we get to a piece of land, we really
want to make sure that it's land, but also
a piece of unvisited land. So right now on
that piece of land, but it's visited, so I
should not wear I don't need to start traversal
here. Likewise, for this position. Eventually,
I'm going to hit some new unvisited land,
in which case I should begin my traversal
at Explorer, this region, and I want to count
up all of these pieces of land. And I should
realize that the final size of this island
would be five, I can compare that five against
my current min, five is bigger, so the size
of two gets to stay. And I can just end up
returning the minimum size by the end of this
algorithm, basically representing this island
of size two, the complexity of this algorithm
is straightforward, we should say that the
size of our input is r times C, because we
have our rows and C columns, in which case
a time complexity is simply our time C, right,
we have to iterate through every row column
within the grid. And even when we begin a
traversal, in the worst case, we could have
an island that spans the entire grid, in which
case it would also be our C. Right. So overall,
our full complexities are time c space complexities
are time C as well. And do know that this
is technically a linear solution in the size
of the grid, right because the grid itself
is exactly r times C positions. So with that,
I think we're ready to code this one up and
try it on your own first. And if you get stuck,
I'll catch you in the walkthrough videos.
See you there. Hey, programmers, Alvin here,
right now let's go over a JavaScript walkthrough
for this minimum Island problem. So we'll
jump right in, make sure you watch the approach
video. As always, this is just a nice spin
off of our classic island hopping logic. But
for a grid graph, right. And so let's start
with the iterative code that can help us begin
a traversal. Starting at every different position
of our grids, that just means some nested
loops. So start by iterating through all of
the rows and columns. So r equals zero, go
up to while r is less than length of the grid,
also do our plus equals one and very similar
loop for my column. But do make sure that
you reference your inner column line because
you could have like a rectangular shaped grid
over here. And what I want to do now is begin
a traversal starting at every row column.
So I'm going to assume I have a helper function
here that does that traversal, I'm going to
call it explore size. That's because in the
long run, I'm interested in the size of that
island, right, so like a number representing
how big or how many positions that island
spans. So I'm going to pass along the grid
information as well as the position. And I
know when it comes to all of these like undirected
graph, traversals should probably guard against
your loops. And I have some foresight here.
So I'm going to pass along a nice visited
set, which I can maintain globally for the
entire traversal because there's only a good
reason to explore a position once right. So
I'll create const visited gonna make it my
neighs JavaScript set. And a few reasons for
that. Well, for one JavaScript set, gives
me O of one lookup, but also o of one insertion.
So it's going to be a really quick data structure
to use. And from there, we probably have to
add some more logic over here to actually
do something with the size but for now, I
think I'm going to switch gears and actually
take a look at building this helper function,
right. So I think the best way to build this
traversal is to use is a deaf purse, typically
just my go to for problem like this, it's
going to take in I know the grid, the row
in the column and also visited, I need some
a base case is very classic base cases, I'm
going to start by checking if this row column
position is inbounds. So my favorite pattern
for that is to split up in some variables
just makes it easier to read and debug. So
I'm going to say is my row inbounds and just
make that like a boolean variable. So I'll
check if, let's say, zero is less than or
equal to the row, I need to say and right,
and that row should be strictly less than
the grid length. So this Boolean would only
be true if it's in bounds, right? And something
very similar for my column bounds should be
between zero and grid zero length. Nice just
like this, I believe. And then I can write
a nice if statement using both clauses. So
I can say, all right, if let's say your row
is not in balance, or your column is not in
balance, then you're definitely at a bound.
So you should probably use some base case
here, right? So we're all choose to return
here is zero, because I want to keep a consistent
number, right consistent return type. That
is, I know that this function has a kind of
goal of returning the size of the explored
islands sizes a number. So even in my base
case, I need to make sure I return some type
of number, returning zero to represent that,
hey, if this is out of bounds, it's not going
to contribute anything into the count of the
size, right, which is good to go. I need some
other base case here. What if my position
is inbounds. But what if it's actually water,
I don't want to count that as well. I only
want to count islands. So land right. So quick
fix, what I'll do is add a new base case,
I can check if my grid at row column, if it's
equal to the water character. So a capital
W can also return zero. If you want it to,
you can also maybe merge these into like a
single if statement, just write a bunch of
ORS, I kind of like them separate because
it's just easy for me to remember what each
of them does write a final conditional have
here is alright, if I make it past both of
these base cases, it might be the case that
this position is land, but it's land I've
already visited. So here's why I work in my
visited logic, I'm going to represent a position,
like we said in the last episode as really
just a string. So I can put it as the members
of my visited set. So I'm going to say position
to have to be the row plus a comma plus the
column. So just representing the position,
that's because I can't add like an array into
a visited set, and then look it up later.
And so if visited has the position, then it's
a duplicate position that I've explored. So
return zero. Otherwise, it's not been visited
yet. So I must be visiting it right now. So
I can add it. Nice. So I have my base cases
laid down. Now I'll need my actual recursive
code. So I'll explore my four neighbors. By
now you should be familiar with this pattern.
So go upwards, a row minus one column pass
on the same visited. So I'm going to explore
my up down left right neighbors respectively.
And I do my recursively buffet theory, right.
So what type do I expect back from these calls,
they're going to give me back a number representing
the size of the island that my neighbor is
a part of. But if my neighbor is part of some
larger Island, then I am too because we're
connected right to our neighbors. And so I
want to create the grand total of all of these
return values. So I'm going to create some
size variable, let's say let size, I'm going
to initialize it to one over here, it's going
to be one and not zero, because the one represents
my current position, my row column. And whatever
these calls return, whatever number I'm just
going to increment my size by that number,
like so. Then finally, I can return our total
size over here. So that will do my depth first
traversal, because it's recursive, but we'll
also tally up the size of this island region.
Cool. So now that I have a working explore
size helper, let's use it in our main function
here. So I'm going to get back a number from
this call. I'll call it my respective size.
And what's great about this logic is if I
have a Island or position I've already seen
before, and I encounter it again in this this
for loop, then I would just return early because
I would hit this base case, right? If something
has already been visited, just automatically
return zero, because I've already considered
it, no reason to consider it again. But now
I need my minimization logic, right, I want
the size of the smallest Island. And they
tell us in the problem that we can totally
assume that your grid contains at least one
island. So I think a great default value here
is to use positive infinity so I can set some
will say min size variable To be positive
infinity, JavaScript, if I make it positive
infinity, I know when I encounter any like
valid Island size, it's going to be less than
infinity. And it should replace it. So now
I can do some min logic here and check. All
right, if the size of this island is less
than the minimum size I have seen so far,
then just replace that min size with that
island. Then after I'm done with all of these
traversals potential reversals, I'll return
my mid size. So some classic patterns here.
There's one nuance that we're not considering
how to run the code, and we can debug it together.
So it looks like we failed example. 00. So
the very first example we expected to answer
to, we accidentally gave back zero. If you
look at that first example, it's pretty obvious
that Yeah, the minimum size is two representing
this island over here. The reason we're giving
back zero is according to our code. Let's
see we're on like the very first iteration,
I'm going to respond it, I know that row is
going to be zero column is going to be zero,
that means my position would be this w over
here. When I make the recursive call, and
I pass along position 00, I know that it's
going to immediately return zero because that
position is water. And I'm going to check
Alright, is that zero, less than infinity
it is, so I'm going to replace min size with
zero. But if I think about it, zero doesn't
even represent a real Island. If an island
has a size of zero, then it's not an island
at all, it was a piece of water, right? And
so I want to add some additional logic here
to only actually look at nonzero quantities.
So only do the comparison if that size is
also valid. So size should be greater than
zero, of course. And we'll want to add these
together. So let's try that again. Just a
little, little detail over there that we need.
Awesome. And there we have a solution for
this minimum Island problem. So we've seen
this pattern a few times now, right or classic
island hopping logic. So when you think about
islands are like connected components of a
graph, this should be your first kind of go
to algorithm. Alright programmers. So that
wraps up our course on graphs. I hope you
learned a ton during the course. I definitely
had a blast making it Be sure to head to Shruti
dotnet, where you can continue to practice
more graph problems, as well as explore any
other data structure algorithm topics. I'll
see you there.